[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Christie
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
really
Oh
[Music]
protests continue across the country
this evening and we want you to know of
course that though there are some
individual protesters who are agitated
it is not the norm these protests are
largely peaceful many people look back
at the demonstrations at Selma and
wonder what would I have done what I
have marched across that bridge would I
be standing on the other side well I
have an answer for you and my answer is
a question what are you doing now now
Tanya how would you describe the
attitude on the ground there we go now
live to our woman in the field Tanya
Frank's Tanya well Chris first I want to
say that was inspiring not many today I
have the courage to say what you just
did your wife is a lucky woman hmm well
that's very kind of you to say Tanya and
might I say you look positively dishy to
see me well as far as the attitude on
the ground you know folks are entirely
peaceful but far from happy just imagine
if every day when you left home you
didn't know whether you'd be coming back
you might be a little upset - well tell
you in my line of work that's always a
possibility but I know that many in the
audience might not understand what
that's like
no Tanya hope was that a man on was that
a man on fire to tell what the flames
Chris might have been a really muscular
lady so Tanya um what are the people on
the ground saying there yeah we gonna
burn this month yeah
a fitting tribute to the memory of
George Floyd Chris who did what a grill
charged evening to be certain no some
people are asking why is this happening
now having things gotten better but
there are still persistent and pervasive
inequities in this country and these
protests are a reaction to that and
aside from a string of isolated
incidents very small things have been
pretty peaceful very tape any final
thoughts Tanya oh hello sir uh what's
your name I'm sorry that was unfair
allow me to reframe the question good
sir where might I ask is time oh she did
[Applause]
the language of the unheard we'll be
right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's June which March love with
Crowder's fifth annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe to learn about and
appreciate all cultures this world has
to offer this week we take you to a
culture known best for its ancestors
penchant for raping and pillaging or as
they call it peaceful protest ladies and
gentlemen and we are here we are with
you I lost my helmet
do you mind get your helmet but I have
tights on there's a social safety net I
can get on board with all right thank
you very much today actually today we're
gonna have Tim pool on the program
that's right and a very exciting
announcement with Tim Poole he's not a
firearm owner but we're gonna change
that after what's the hashtag tonight
hashtag is Crowder riot stream Crowder
riot stream so we did this last Saturday
and we had close to 50,000 of you guys
watching and let me be really clear what
I think is important about this is we
are going to be watching CNN live and
fact-checking it we have read the Bandit
of course here in standby yes so this
way you couldn't watch CNN right with us
and you can go huh and then we'll bring
up what's actually happening go oh yeah
that's the whole purpose to this is that
the the coverage and I will say this I
actually was depressed this week really
I know you know what else what else is
he it was a new form of I mean more I
was more depressed because I felt like
we didn't make a dent I mean we had a
million people who watched who tuned in
and then I just thought well maybe this
old maybe that the coverage from people
like us not just ourselves will keep the
media accountable and I'll be
acknowledging the violence it's only
gotten worse it's only gotten worse
where they've been talking about
peaceful protests in general oh by the
way we do have a promo code its promo
code Viking you get $20 off I believe
before we move on what Vikings oh I
thought you're excited a lot of rape
that's one eight it's there raise all
day if Joe Biden were a Viking he would
be a lone wolf because they'd be like
are you sniffing why don't you
immediately rape well you know I don't
want the backlash and why do you care
what women say and I don't know why I
don't know why they sound like name took
from the First Nations people as
cultural appropriation months by the way
send us your tweets let us know you can
tweet me at s Crowder and we will pick
your month sorry your your your country
next week throughout the let's you
apropriate is to appreciate it's
important in your costumes I think we
should have let people know we were
doing Norway so they could have dressed
up but it's I tell you what if there's
someone out there who has the time we
will be streaming for potentially three
to five hours yeah send in your costume
and we will give away something coffee I
mean if you've got a Viking outfit just
laying around
stinger Viking facts more to this
program yeah yeah I forgot that it was
Norway facts but yeah so Norway is home
of the world's longest road tunnel the
Nobel Peace Prize and 5.3 million
impossibly good-looking people the
world's longest rotom
road tunnel yeah yeah finally Harriet
Tubman had to pee I'd say so and there's
a small village in Norway named Hell
which is home to over 1500 fornicators
adulterers sodomites thieves and
drunkards yes right yeah absolutely and
then skiing was invented in Norway
skiing skiing they should ski me yeah
yeah that's racist the skiing was
invented in Norway by Gregory burov
which was an expansion on his first
invention long ass shoes you know it
really is a shame to see what's happened
to a once industrious people that's true
um by the way we have a drinking game
let's bring the drinking game rules to
night any time they mentioned the word
peaceful protest or imply that people
are peaceful you drink anytime they
imply that Trump is a racist or that
America is racists or that there's
systemic racism you drink and we highly
recommend that you do not drink hard
liquor yeah unless you
doing it for a while no Brautigan can't
handle it we can't no but it's funny no
yes that's okay
let me be really clear as we talk about
peaceful protests and I just need to get
this out there so that I don't have to
use any papers we have at least 12
deaths thus far from the protest at
least 12 over 370 officers who have been
severely injured over 10,000 arrests
over 25 million dollars in property
damage in Minneapolis alone so that's
over 12 deaths nearly four probably
after tonight 400 officers injured of
course many of them black officers one
black officer killed two black officers
killed as far as we know 25 million in
Minneapolis alone in damage and of
course the Democrat talking point right
now as they want to defund the police
that's the conversation defund the
police which was echoed by one portion
of the squad the Burt Ward of the squad
Rasheed it's late yeah she's a horrible
human being um before I I do have some
opening thoughts but before that let's
see what's going on at CNN so you know
exactly what you're in for
over over a hundred and seven thousand
dead more than 40 million unemployed our
economy is in tatters almost two million
Americans infected all that's an
operating system over just four months
behind this awful moment of the death of
George Floyd let me just take a moment
and offer my deepest condolences to the
family and to the community of
Minneapolis that is what that was
Trump's for anyone buying this is no
doubt they're buying this [ __ ] that
Donald Trump is to blame for the economy
it's an element and the fact is you guys
condemned him for wanting to open it
back up yeah somehow his fault we can
take this well you know he put a travel
ban and the Wuhan and China by the way
we have a travel ban from the Congo
cause Ebola Megyn that's true yeah Ebola
said kovat hold my beer I don't know you
know this guy's but Ebola is a dick yeah
way worse it's a real problem
yeah what did you like to hate
Samaritan's Purse you know because of
the white christian people they went
into Liberia when Ebola had a 50% death
rate can you imagine if COBIT at a 50%
death rate people wouldn't be on again
off again masks like JLo and Ben Affleck
furs I couldn't think of who her husband
right now but it was Bennifer that's the
original benefit the point it wouldn't
be on again again mask below the nasal
cavity like the airline workers did
Delta when I was traveling they would be
hiding in their house and of course you
would still have a gun shortage because
it would be shooting anyone who comes
within sneezing distance of their humble
abode it's a really different deal watch
a movie where they have so documentary
where they have doctors going in they
are they have layer upon layer upon
layer upon layer right yeah before they
go in they treat it very seriously this
is something completely different
yeah they bring the volume down a Tim
from HR just while we're doing this if
it doesn't distract folks everybody a
points been made over and over but on
the left you have a guide saying
something about like covet and then on
the right you have a bunch of people not
standing six feet apart
yeah he's not berating them ever or
anything and by the way I am calling
every single church out there every
single Church open on Sunday every
single house of worship open on Sunday
people shouldn't be able to go out and
roll over cop cars and you can't go to
church unless you're six feet apart if
you need to be succeed apart of the
church and put on a mask fine they don't
get to commit mass felonies and shoot
officers all churches open all
businesses open nope is there anything
less is no question than being an
[ __ ] in the street yeah that's out of
my eyes I'm kicking this woman because
she was wearing a Mogga hat and it's a
part of the American fabric it's
absolutely essential all churches all
businesses open now or the left you
support the United States military
coming in and kicking ass without mercy
take your choice and every single pastor
out there who if you don't open your
church you're a [ __ ]
go ahead and everyone tell me statement
well I would expect the truth yeah it is
it's a vision if you don't you're a
[ __ ] well look I would say this pastors
football whatever
I think they should is this what you
might tell us what you
I think we're gonna see much the same
that we've seen here except I think what
we're gonna see more of is people like
this coming on and saying you a US army
generals are against rum can't you see
that these people of great credibility
are against Donald Trump for what he has
been doing like generals don't have an
agenda like generals don't have
political beliefs that could skew them
one way or the other they're completely
you know neutral arbiters of truth and
that's not that's not really what's
going on and then we're also gonna see
more of the black leaders in the
community pushing more and more and more
there are some peaceful protest people
walking the street that's peaceful it
doesn't tend to stay that way but yeah
come on I stepped on it guys sorry but I
think what we're gonna see though is
obviously what we've seen every single
other night this has been going on every
single major city in the United States
on fire front peaceful protests as soon
as yeah and we're not gonna see much
reporting on it on CNN we're gonna go to
yeah well jumping off an earlier point
that you made I think that this probably
is the closest thing to a religious
sacrament that the left has right is
watching people yeah again loot and
chaos chaos is their only religious
sacrament that they have so yes of
course this needs to be protected but
yeah again Church yeah
stay far far away and not worth the risk
I think we need to like we do with with
change do you have any thoughts are does
anyone I want I mean I'm gonna go I'm
looking forward to seeing oh they try to
spin this okay I want you to speak your
piece cousin buddy I got a lot to say go
ahead no you got it no I was so but what
one thing before you go we were laughing
that it's breaking that II the
protesters are erupting around the
country [ __ ] chicken dance it's the
work of which I am most proud someone
turn that into a gif and let everyone
know he's in tights I think language
really matters because they're going to
say peaceful protest okay
don't do it on tests that are not
violent on everyone else because it's
funny
don't do it on me because you'll be
fired I will be a drunk I think my
threats become empty
[Laughter]
it's been years wife's today for me
hired rehired I mean does that count so
this met there are no peaceful
protesters at this point what do I mean
okay if you are there right now and you
are behind the police line people don't
understand as they go police line
coppers and you see for example that one
one example of the police who was still
pushing the barricade when people in
front of the barricade well let me
explain something to you how do you
think the firefighters get in to put out
the bombs that you've set Massholes
huh there was a fire I believe in
Minneapolis with a woman and a child in
the house and you know what the
firefighters were coming to save them
and then the protesters the mobs
peacefully mind you because they didn't
punch a firefighter right in the head I
think it was because I didn't want the
recoil to go through this to reverberate
through their fists cuz they're wearing
helmets I bet you if they weren't
wearing facemasks they probably would
have been punched in the face but thank
God
let me let me ask you this how is that
peaceful and let me ask you this by the
way I want to be really clear about
something I think everyone needs to
protect their stuff that's your house
your family I am not calling for anyone
to go out to them into the streets and
be a vigilante okay now not right now
I'll explain where that changes in a
second hint that's about defunding the
police so the firefighters are trying to
how do you think the firefighters get
through right the police cars have push
bumpers and so when you block a police
barricade or start you set up a
barricade so police officers can't get
through you are also blocking the
subsequent first responders behind them
the heroes remember I know they're not
on tick-tock shaking their Internet but
other than the firefighters trying to
put out an tufa bombs or kind of heroes
you know well consider it one opining
here if you're a family member let's say
you have your wife let's say you have
your wife in that house and a child and
there's a fire and you can't an open to
open up the door because of the
backdraft maybe you're up on the roof
and you see you see the fire trucks
coming y'all thank God we're saved and
then you see a mass of what the media
calls peaceful protesters commonly
referred to as [ __ ] by the way our
rating tonight because we cannot predict
what you will see there will be a lot of
violent footage I know a lot of kids
watch our show I really she ate it but I
want to make sure that you understand
there are some disturbing footage that
we will see tonight because we have to
do the job at the media won't but let's
go back to that your home your daughters
in the house and you see the fire trucks
and then you see a swarm of peaceful
protesters stop them I just start doing
this looks like Donald Trump you see
yeah stop the biggest one now what are
you how do you feel let me change that
scenario you're on the roof and you of a
sniper rifle do you save your family do
you take do you shoot one into the crowd
so they disperse now I ask you that
because that's an actual scenario that's
not an extreme scenario that actually
happened now god forbid someone actually
ends up taking out people on rooftops
though the Koreans have no issue with it
Korea when you do that you would it on
you someone in that situation and a lot
of people think you're only a violent
protestor if you are currently in the
process of punching a cop no if the
police have set up a perimeter at this
point if they have told you that you
cannot be somewhere that's because they
have a job as do firefighters to protect
the citizens who pay taxes so that they
can enjoy the fruits of the rule of law
which by the way we now understand they
can't they can't the police cannot
protect you thank God for the Second
Amendment which you also wanted to take
away so when they say peaceful
protesters know if you are in front of a
police line or behind a peace line you
are not a peaceful protester if there's
violence erupting and you stay there and
you still keep chanting with your fists
up you are not a peaceful protest your
car no cop says step back and you do not
you are not a peaceful protester I want
to be as clear as humanly possible now
if my car is going through and you swore
my car and I encourage every American
out there if you swarm a car guess what
I'm not slowing down you're now L feed
bump I'm going to run over protesters so
it sounds like I'm driving on Braille
yes we are you you're driving over
Stevie Wonder's Playboy no it's just I'm
trying to block the firefighting truck
behind me no problem with it because you
see too many people being dragged from
their cars in BM so what's the first
step
stay home avoid these scenarios stay
safe but do not let people kick in your
windshield and drag you from the car
because just like David Dorn the baby is
never going to tell your story yeah you
won't be in the news you won't have a
mural I need to be really clear about
that by the way the thousands of black
people killed in the past years at the
hands of black people you'll not get a
wall or a mural no George George
he does and we'll get into that in a
second which also really pisses me off
what also pisses me off is comparing
this to the founding photos this is like
revolution do you have any idea how much
the revolutionaries wanted peace have
you ever actually read any of the
founding correspondent the letters the
documents before the Boston Tea Party
which by the way very tame very you're
putting tea bags in a harbor yeah okay
any idea the kind of torture that people
face under the monarchy they tried to
broker peace because they didn't want
taxation without representation they
tried to go a peaceful route and then
they weren't able to these protests
started absolutely violently it's not
close yeah well yeah well it's speaking
of the Revolutionary War as the
commander like the commander's actually
told their soldiers as they saw the
first boats from the British come in
right don't shoot first right they said
wait until you hear a shot so they're
saying wait until one of you either gets
shot or you hear somebody else right so
that they wouldn't have to wouldn't
listen nobody could say that this was an
office right twelve people been shot
dead over 300 shot injured so guess what
yeah shots fired
you're right very different sorry shots
fired you don't get to go into Syria
hang out and be oh I'm just so I'm just
here behind with Isis I'm not I'm not
doing anything it doesn't matter if they
say Isis clear out well I'm not doing
anything but that guy's burning a
Christian alive in a cage well I don't
support that well you could have fooled
me cuz you're wearing just a nunnery
Rosie
also let me be really clear about
something speaking from a Christian
perspective if you kneel I see this
going around and Joe Biden kneeled and
Bill DeBlasio kneeled by the way who
demanded the badge of that one officer I
don't know man of the badge turned out
the officer only pulled out his gun
after his friend was almost knocked
unconscious by a brick that's the kind
of politicization you're seeing here if
I have a friend who's hit in the head
with a brick and have a gun I am pulling
it out and if the guy keeps coming for
was another brick Fanning the hammer
again they're not encouraging violence
going out and seeking it but we cannot
disarm our own police officers and God
forbid like the left wants you to disarm
people in their own homes
let me be clear about needling this is
something that's going on right now
you're gonna kneel for your white
privilege
first off you should never apologize for
something that you haven't done why
because then your true apologies ring
hollow your apologies need to be sincere
as a
because I see Jesse Jackson talking
about one shepherd and one sheep and I
don't even know that he's read a Bible
any time yeah I might have an advent
calendar the reverend is an honorary
right it's not quite rare ii title yeah
and he got it from from phoenix [ __ ]
university yeah it was melo I got it
from DeVry prick if someone demands that
you kneel and you kneel again I don't
want this you're a [ __ ] you are a [ __ ]
you do not kneel I'm explaining you as a
Christian deal i only kneel before the
kingdom of god i only kneel at the
throne of god if you don't like it you
can tune out right now sorry if it
offends you I'm a Christian I kneel at
the throne of God and by the way I want
to be clear
Jesus God and everyone says we worship
the same God no not exactly because you
have an Islam where Mohammed basically
said that Jesus was a fraud and he
didn't actually get crucified and it was
actually people replace the body so
that's actually blasphemy
so I kneel at the throne of God Jesus or
as I call him good guy God and you
Punk's are absolutely no God I want to
be very clear I do not kneel for a man
and I do not kneel for someone who wants
to intimidate me now finally let me be
really clear about that some people got
mad that I talked about this on Glenn
Beck's show this morning I think I've
been very clear that George Floyd wrong
yeah did not deserve and should not have
died at the hands of that crosser I
think right now they might be trying to
they might be trying to put on more
harsh charge and I think they did
against drugs then it gets dropped they
can continue the riots yeah you can't
actually create motive and say that this
guy went out and wanted to lynch a black
guy but I did say third degree murder
manslaughter absolutely
yeah it's surely been very clear that
should not have happened doesn't matter
that he had meth and fentanyl in her
system yeah that doesn't matter he
shouldn't have if you have ventanilla
meth in your system and you have a heart
attack it's the police officers job to
try and keep you alive yeah control us
period
now separate sentence let me explain to
you why it matters that George Floyd was
a scummy violent criminal didn't deserve
to die period end of sentence I write a
good and now let me explain this this is
a man who long long rap sheet offender
this is a man who personally sought out
a pregnant woman black woman by the way
invaded her house
loaded pistol into her gut while his
other thug-buddies lan sacked her house
and he got five years for it this is why
it matters that does not mean that he
deserved to die at the hands of police
officers despite you know what maybe he
only had meth and fentanyl in his system
because he's an addict that I understand
it's a disease and yet control over it
doesn't mean he was still a criminal I'm
not necessarily convinced he was flying
on the straight and narrow should not
have died in the police officers but
here is why it matters do you know how
many black unarmed black men have been
killed by cops last year anyone have an
estimate because now they're saying
genocide right right right
how would you think genocide have to be
at least a thousand yeah ten ten ten
unarmed black men 19 white guys by the
way yeah during the low 30s in the
Barack Obama you're so we're making
progress and of those 10 most of them
deserved it doesn't matter if you have a
gun or not if you reach for a cop's gun
and if you charge a police officer does
a strong chance that you get shot a
lower chance mind you then white people
that's a statistic that nobody wants to
talk about white people are shot more
often with TSA officers when you
actually take into account interactions
young people say what white or point
people are a higher percentage of the
population doesn't matter the matter the
total of laughs if a hundred black
people have an interaction with a police
officer
they are 25% less likely to get shot
than if a hundred white people have an
interaction with a police officer
why are the crimes matter of George
Floyd because that's an evil son of a
[ __ ] anyone here ever had a pregnant
wife imagine someone jamming a loaded
pistol into her gut yeah why does that
matter because that's a bigger problem
facing the black community today that is
not a typical black people commit crimes
the hottest ones we're talking about
this and a disproportionate rate both
against white people
and against members of their black
community if we want reform that is what
we want to reform George Floyd deserve
to die then if there were husband he
could have shot George Floyd and been
within his rights just perform has
nothing to do with the police officer
but you know where this matters to
because this is the emblem there were 10
people shot last year by police officers
most officers now are carrying body cam
footage yeah you picked the guy who
jammed a loaded pistol into a pregnant
woman's belly with five guys and
pistol-whipped her
hey hey if you're gonna pick someone to
paint a mural can you find one who
doesn't act like an evil person just one
doesn't deserve to die at the hand of
the cops really clear but that is evil
that is premeditated
evil pick one of the ten who actually
was a law-abiding citizen Mike Brown
nope punch the cop was reaching for his
gun Trayvon Martin no was promulgated
into the ground Tamir rice no was aiming
guns at people in a park chorong gaines
note was holding her daughter as a human
shield with a loaded shotgun my point
here is this you want this to be when
you say Joyce George Floyd is all of us
well what we don't say Jeffrey Dahmer is
all of us Jeffrey Dahmer should never
have been killed by police when being
taken into custody
no one should that's the rule of law why
can't you pick someone who hasn't
assaulted a pregnant woman with a gun
yes that's my point yes it matters
you want to address the problem that's
the problem that you need to address now
what are we talking about what's the end
goal here when they talk about
revolution what revolution there should
be a mission statement like we had with
the United States what's the point
what's the mission here police reform
well the only thing we've seen
articulated is defunding the police
entirely echoed by Rasheeda Slade ooh
ooh really because that changes a whole
defund the police well thank God you
guys didn't succeed and taking away the
Second Amendment if you defund the
police guess what you're not gonna fare
so well hotshot it's not people from
urban you want to go out to the suburbs
it's not gonna be some DNA a country boy
can survive Hank Williams lot of shoots
they know how to skin a deer they know
how to feel dress a cat for all I know I
know I do weird stuff people scare me
you're the banjo from deliverance
Louisville is there I'm it's a bourbon
kid you guys want to skimp on the police
oh well guess what that changes right
now I'm saying don't go out to everybody
stay home stay safe if there's no police
force now you have vigilante justice
because it's the only justice now you
don't have people roaming the streets
and treating block parties and going out
to preemptively stop you from invading
their house you want to defund the
police let me be really clear about this
you defund the police you know what the
most valuable person is at that point
and of course their goal is take away
the Second Amendment then defund the
police profit it'd be like Arkham Asylum
you know as most unanimity defund the
police okay you could it's not the
strong guy it's not the guy who's a
member of the who's a member of the
Crips who needs to take some shooting
lessons because he fires like this and
couldn't the
broadside of a barn it's not the guy
just wrong that's not the world champion
UFC fighter
it's my half-asian lawyer bill Richman
who's an IDP a shooter who can split a
playing card at a hundred yards you line
up every single top ten competitors from
world Strongest Man he can kill them all
within 5 seconds for me it might take 16
the guy who's from the country the
stupid little country [ __ ] half half
Asian slightly chubby guys man Lutheran
lady looks good he's the one beef on the
police well guess what you're gonna go
out first it won't even be closed well
yet so the only the only kind of change
the only kind of action that put y'all
back and change Oh a change yes the only
action that the left allows is top-down
change right right so but what you're
saying is that we need bottom-up change
we need inside-out change not outside in
so they're only allowed to change the
outside if you change them there
according to their worldview if you
change your environment than everything
else then all the morality is just sorts
in two layers and everything's fine but
they don't want layers they don't want
any kind of there's no ground
there's no real change does not happen
that way and here's the thing if you
want to look at an America where you
have a defunded police force just look
at these major cities in the United
States when the police have been removed
from an area and looting rioting needed
breaking into every store destroying
stuff the very base basest thing that we
could possibly do as a human population
we do it when police and authority are
gone when the the punishment for our
crime is gone we do that and when we
talk about justice right everybody's
calling for justice right now I've seen
a few tweets that say this is not it we
just want equal justice and I'm like
well hold on I thought that the cop was
fired I think that rattles justice
there's a moon arresting somebody trying
them and either convicting them or
setting them free if they weren't guilty
like I thought justice was a process and
we are right in the middle of it very
quickly in the middle of it so what do
you want I don't honestly know I can't
go to your protester right now and say
tell me what you want well I want
justice for Michael fo well the only
thing that we can do right now George
Floyd the only thing that we can do
right now is try the per
who's guilty delorean and change the
situation and we can all get together
and say hey let's train the police
officers you know that's get the Union
so that we can fire bad ones and get
those guys out of here and let's all
treat cops with respect did you see that
when I made the moon pie joke oh that
was all right yeah I think that's that's
where the definition of social justice
comes in right right so it's not that
they want individual justice they don't
want this particular and there was a
stream up on the spot and that's not
justice well they ought to defund the
police right all right
and if Americans knew this they'll not
talk about this on CNN if Americans knew
this right now you have what is it 58%
support using the National Guard I think
it only 17% know if you said hey by the
way receipt it slave and the leaders of
this movement have openly expressed that
their desire their end game is to defund
the police you would see that number
skyrocket to probably 90 and let me
reiterate this if you have a conniption
fit when people want to defund Planned
Parenthood but you want to defund the
police you're an [ __ ] I don't have a
whole lot of time for your arguments you
want a welfare state you want to make
sure that people get free health care
free television free phones free
abortions but no police which is very
few legitimate per views of government
oh my gosh these people they don't want
guns by the way the gun stores are
picked clean yet another answer I highly
recommend you go pick up a Walther if
you're looking for a handgun but well
you can place I've gone they don't have
them so let me tell you what else oh
that save is really good if you can find
that of course Glock are really good
HK are really good there are some
Reuters that are good facts lesson so
much Holland about you being safe right
now I recommend the Walther but they're
clear sold out contract Walter because
we can't do any more well and anytime
you you put the military the United to
the US territory to help you have to be
careful right there's a reason that we
don't typically do this and that's fine
to say hey you got to be careful but
everybody's saying like this is the end
of American democracy this is the first
steps towards it like Gary gas Kasparov
is tweeting things about it the chess
champion who thinks he can write books
on what it's like how what is that
yeah exactly he's very smart guy but not
in this and he's saying this is the end
of American democracy see they're
putting troops in the streets so that
they can kind of take away all your
freedoms no no no we're the side that
wants more freedom we're the side that
wants you to be able to defend yourself
and not have to worry about people
killing you because you're happy while
driving down the wrong Street
do you notice they pulled all these
troops out whenever you started
attacking yes there's a finish what's up
this is a 10 to a 10 right so what's
your name a clear yeah well yeah and the
federal government is stepping in
because state government city government
stands not only right that but family
governments and self government we're
like we're not even controlling
ourselves right so that's why they're
stepping in oh yeah every level of their
mass rather than protecting their stuff
taking up arms to protect their family
and their homes right I'm going out
committing acts of violence against
routes but protecting their stuff you
have people who are kneeling right don't
do that don't wrestling to evil and
these people are evil anyone who demands
that you kneel and is not God is likely
an evil person that's a good test if
some kneel and apologize for what I
guess I should do this take him in the
nice fella
you're probably about to hit her and
your wallets gone well well yeah
whatever you think in your head kneeling
means it actually means submission and
worship worship yeah yeah so I didn't
notice your Tupac shirt so you know what
okay how about taking me well that's a
bad one because was one hell of a track
that was actually black on black crime
with Tupac died so that's at exam right
yeah and biggie
that's right well let's go to CNN a
little bit because that's why we're here
let's see what they have to say they're
showing protests he was right it's about
leadership what's the hashtag for this
dreaming earlier on the man who
videotaped the the person was beaten in
Texas that's right so please we want to
get the sounds that have a large
platform in an audience we want to make
sure that people are getting accurate
information so tweet me it is matter
let's watch them
CNN here but they know better
[Music]
have to use a damn helicopter as a
weapon of intimidation
why does stupid Oh weapon intimidation
always thank Y up next new details
reflect in court in the Ahmad Arbor II
murder case another black man who's
killing was caught on video what an
investigator said about the last minutes
mr. Aubrey's life yeah do you guys know
this story they're now saying that one
eyewitness said the guy yeah right some
called him the N word after he shot him
yeah
so somebody somewhere said something cuz
there is the reason people are outraged
is because we're video graphic evidence
and no one saw that right right right
hmm by the way yeah that could not be
less relevant if he committed an actual
crime and murder an innocent person
right just like when that uh that guy
was a justice for a Scurlock right this
was something I guess this all happened
since we did the last dream justice for
wasn't James for locked I think this
filmmaker
Spurlock is the filmmaker Morgan
Spurlock is the film yeah yeah not
supersize me guys yes that was an
example where they said oh he was shot
you know and the guy and there was one
witness of course a black person he
yelled en word well actually every
single other witness who was asked to
provide a testimony or an account
independently no one saw that so there's
a reason that eyewitness testimony is
considered the least reliable for me yes
what actually happened and we might even
be able to have this footage you know
what let's bring that up the security
camera footage because this was the
number one trend on Twitter justice for
James Scurlock and everyone was
protesting and taking a knee now he's
not attending anymore why because the
footage came out he was being pummeled
repeatedly by two or three men he then
took his gun that he had on him and full
right to use fired two warning shots to
scare them off then when he got up from
his bloody huddled mess Scurlock tackled
him down and started punching him and he
shot him so of course the video graphic
evidence was reviewed and I believe the
judge or DA said okay you're free to go
and people had a fit justice justice
justice well I understand maybe there
was a lack of justice and that the
people who ran off from the warning
shots should also spend a yeah the drunk
tank I don't know it's shot the ass on
the footage this is Scurlock that was
the number one hashtag for 12 hours
oh is that I only saw the security
camera footage I mean cell phone does
this actually show the altercation right
here Wow or is this just the altercation
beforehand
it looks like it's beforehand it's
beforehand yeah there's actual footage
from the security camera that shows ya
eyes on him beating him so find that
that's what the judge actually releases
and you have every you have every right
to defend yourself I don't know where we
got the idea that if you threaten
somebody if you violently attack
somebody if you try to pull somebody out
of their car in the midst of a protest
when they would like I don't know where
we got the idea that the response should
always be calm and it always should be
proportional to the threat like if
somebody's pulling me out of my car I
don't know what proportional is I have
no idea if they're gonna kill me right
outside of this or if they're gonna hang
me from the bridge by my ankles and pull
my pants down and right you know I don't
know what they're gonna do proportional
when a man named James Gunn exactly wife
stuff you have no idea if he's gonna
pull the trigger and laugh yeah or if
he's just using it to keep her there
which are both wrong you don't know the
end of this you have no idea yeah oh by
the way so we have this all right
remember keep in mind before you run
this this was I don't do we have audio
on it or no no this was the trend for
several hours and there were new marches
that we're starting justice for Scurlock
and you can see why it went away pretty
quickly let's bring this up okay so
you'll see here the altercation look
there they mount him I believe is name
is Gardner they're both beating him up
right there on the street they're both
beating him up the man on the bottom he
fires warning shots so they get up and
run away now he gets up gets tackled
again oh and they're choosing that's
show the video because because the
shameful part and that is where the max
shoots the person off of him yeah you
know gosh self-defense you know why you
don't want to show that because he was
still punching him while he got shot no
we need to be really clear about that no
have they mentioned the police officer I
just forgot David David or Nordahl on
seeing it at any point I haven't seen it
no none at all okay here they are
they're back justice for a mod Arbor II
rally in Georgia so many rallies for
judgment it's really hard to keep tires
point he was 25 years old he was out for
a jog and he was horrific Lee chased and
gunned down 12 miles from his house
charged in the case for just a little
room investigators share new and
sickening details about the killing it
is hard to hear and we want to warn you
it is hard to watch this but this
happened the only reason we know about
it is because these murderers were so
proud of what they did to a fellow he
being because of the color of his skin
that they videotaped at all
yeah and called the cops a bit racist
who's accused committing a hate crime
calls the police right away this is
where possible I want the whole world to
know that I should be fried right
exactly doesn't make any sense at all
three white men here's the evidence a 25
year old black man running through their
day by the way if we were to say black
and white he'd be racist right was
chased and ultimately executed at the
hands of the three defendants Gregory
McMichael and his son Travis and William
rowdy Brian jr. they knew it was Norway
the problem is money yeah yeah the minks
initially told authorities they thought
Arbor it was a burglary suspect the
prosecution says Harbury had done
nothing wrong Ricky was a burglary
suspect and the police can say he didn't
do anything wrong doesn't change that he
would they thought he was yeah call the
cops and said they thought he was and
things can be true didn't I say they had
interacted with him before I don't think
I don't know I thought somebody said
that sorry I didn't know if that was in
fact Arbor II was out jogging the day he
died friend says what he looked to do
prosecutors can tell the in cargo shorts
and temporal arteries death he wasn't in
timberlands women saying it wasn't
jogging attalia pickup not saying he
deserve to die of course not but I'm
saying there's plenty of reason for one
to be suspicious especially in a
neighborhood have been many break-ins
before they finally cornered him one of
the suspects captured our breeze fine
alone I see that's are we grabbing his
gun just to be clear you guys saw that
right yeah grabbing the man's gun now
that's horrible but he might be grabbing
the guy who has his gun who had known
maybe no intention of using it and then
the other guy grabs it you go oh shoot
he can take my gun and he can kill me oh
shoot I'm trapped and then all of a
sudden it escalates
just like we see with these riots which
I said please don't do this it's going
to escalate more people are going to die
that is a horrible enforcement situation
they did call the cops
they shouldn't have brought out they
shouldn't have filled their wet period
on that idea yeah but none of this was
new and that's that's the kind of
vigilante justice if you think that
that's vigilante justice somebody
pulling out a gun to stop a would-be
potential burglars
[Laughter]
he looks like Hannibal Lecter right
there right about the lips little [ __ ]
you know that guy that's his face got
eaten off and yeah whatever that guy's
was all the men had maintained that all
they were trying to do that day even
though two of the men were armed was
trying to have a conversation with the
Marberry
always is that a crime everyone here is
always armed they mentioned that black
suspect three white male suspects and
those men say they weren't do anything
wrong though they were armed do you know
that armed citizens citizens with
concealed carry permits are the most
law-abiding citizens in the country why
do you mention that unless you want
people to think that being armed is a
crime because you want to take away the
Second Amendment oh and by the way
coming down the pike defund the police
ass all this yeah this is from constant
fear he that if what it looks like it
looks like he may have actually been on
a jog even those 12 miles from his house
whatever he's on a jog
but he's been told his whole life white
people hate me white people hate me so
whenever he sees white people with a gun
he automatically jumps at them and then
tries to take their gun then it
escalates after these riots do you think
that people are more likely or less
likely to train a gun on you if you're
simply taking the Drake there's only
things Rome's when you don't have the
right to be on that private property
when when these riots are going on
they're being echoed and gun stores are
being cleared out because nobody
believed that the media is selling them
and that this is largely a peaceful
protest across the country do you think
that someone like an armory is more
likely or less likely to end up a victim
of being shot this is what concerns me
so much and please everyone out there
Christians atheists alike you need to
pray and guard your heart against actual
racism my fear right now is that you are
going to have a bunch of young people
become more racist than we've ever seen
because they've grown up in a
post-racial America and you have a media
saying because black because black
because race yes cuz race and they're
going on a second over a dozen people
shot over 300 officers killed my
friend's house was burned down why is it
make you an answer and Cooper he goes
because black because black because
black because race no no it's criminal
behavior yeah it's a serious anarchy but
when you keep selling it as a
black-white thing and the results are
Anarchy chaos and violence are going to
have young white kids who weren't here
for the progress post Civil Rights Act
they're just gonna go a hold on a second
why why the media is saying that these
black people this they're also violent
why are they also why why are they all
so violent why is Don Lemon Anderson
Cooper and Chris Cuomo telling me that
black people are violent not all black
people are violent of course we need to
make sure that folks understand that but
you wouldn't know what if it were a tune
into the media they're telling you it's
because race because race because race
because race sooner or later you have a
generation of kids who go well you know
what because race yeah let's say none of
the three guys let's all assume that
none of the three guys actually used the
n-word a tan in the AMA dobry case right
but it doesn't what I'm saying is it
doesn't matter now because somebody said
that they did and so in everybody's head
no matter if somebody remotely let's say
we find out that that it didn't actually
happen it's stuck in people's heads now
yeah so it doesn't matter there is no
Halle Dean you see there is no coming
back from that right because once you
put it in people's heads especially in
this canceled culture like we have yeah
you say something it doesn't matter if
it's true or not you're gonna cancel
anyways yeah that's my favorite funny
he'll leave some kind of impression in
people's mind yeah there's somebody
photoshop's about a bad tweet and
somebody's it actually does make you
think negative or the Bible explains why
you don't kneel for a violent mob
because let me ask you this has anyone
had any success with apologizing to the
outraged mob yeah we'd love to hear the
story of the one that energized to the
torch mob to the canceled culture torch
mob get devoured yeah how do you think
it works out if you kneel to the
actually physically violent mob it
doesn't work you submit and you become
serfs they're not merciful they're not
convey meaning the mob of people that
includes anta for that includes matter I
have to hold every single time because
the media keeps saying race race race
race and I'm trying to frame this as
good versus evil but the mob is never
merciful they're incapable of it because
they're a mob yeah well then the people
kneeling show that they are afraid Yeah
right people yeah there actually is a
deep fear inside them good right to
kneel before the Gestapo maybe we should
ask that's a good question I think you
know one of the things that really
frustrates me about this is people like
Al Sharpton I think you had mentioned
Jesse Jackson earlier every single
my tights do it they are very light so
they kind of blend in defend us oh yes
hold on one second I want to see what's
happening guys talking through a gas man
something better on the other side
that's for kovat that's not forensic
Elmo those are certainly were also the
tear gas xenon 10 days into this let's
go to Chris right now Chris our damsel
boy like you very much I am Chris Cuomo
welcome to you by the way I'm glad he is
follow me on Twitter people watch his
show that he'll dance until he assumes
they stumbled across some accident Chris
Cuomo missed a few I have some stories
to get to Chris is my name my brother
Graham not Andrew I am my own man whose
name is Chris Eyre bomb tune in if CNN
can tune in to any place right now in
that city where you are not hearing like
yeah this is Chris Cuomo is there any
way that you can tune into an area of
town once Chris Chris of domestic
terrorist rated oh yeah I didn't know I
was going to have to walk yeah hey
mister gas mask see if you can walk over
that peaceful mushroom cloud
[Applause]
over there it's a lady okay so very very
polite very polite get binary nice if
you don't they're no longer peaceful
rise guess what a firetruck I need to
come through that barrier because we
just heard something going off and there
could be a woman and child and that has
happened that's not an extreme example
it happens every day
or maybe a David Doran is bleeding out
because someone wanted a Westinghouse
and so they need to make sure that they
have enough space and they have a
perimeter so they can get to save that
man's life when an officer respectfully
says please stay behind the perimeter
and you don't you're no longer peaceful
and I hear gasps away well and the
perimeter is also set up because there's
a history of violence in that area so
the setting up this perimeter because of
very attractions in point history yeah
yeah yeah that just does it when I saw
that naked fight scene I think that was
a my point was if you have a compromised
position right so if you start to have
people penetrate your perimeter right I
know this sounds really tawdry keep
doing it I saw it in a glint in your eye
sir how dare you how dare you on this
show right but never if you think about
this if you have a perimeter and
somebody starts to break through that
perimeter all of a sudden everybody
who's back can you kiss to us I wanna
hear what this one who you couldn't kill
your donkey and you jumped on an
cartwheeling with diticom that was
[Music]
basically shut up
and read the bandit have a clip ready of
people who absolve officers after this
so we can contrast he's not angry at all
yeah slogan sir sir that's not a reason
but wow he's uh
you can't are you there can we bring
this down let's bring up reg the bandit
reg the Bandit our brilliant researcher
who's an absolute monster reg are you
there sir mute all right you were muted
I can't see him can we see him at all
I'd like to I'd like to I'd like to see
reg the band the band a little band all
right good hey can you do us a favor do
we have a clip here of any officers
being assaulted because we know that
over 300 officers have been obviously
injured seriously or critically and
twelve people have died he just very
kindly and respectfully said please stay
back from the perimeter then the
response was well guess what your your
violence does he says it do and there's
another man this is a peaceful protester
yeah because he's peaceful saying you're
individuals you can leave or you can
stay that is a direct a direct buckin of
the wall officer doesn't matter if you
say it nicely when the officers please
we need you to move back in the
privilege after he said nicely please
leave if you don't there's this
underlying philosophy that these two
guys that it's Galit Aryan philosophy
that these two guys have the same amount
of authority right exactly right that's
that's the baseline assumption of this
guy with the goggles is that he thinks
that he and this actual officer right
both belong on this corner when it's a
lawful order by the way you the state
does have a right to put in place a
curfew and you have to abide by that
otherwise you do go to jail let's see if
we
here and then I want to go to register
bandit if we have them up let's see if
they're all right so Nick hard to make
out Chris I'm sorry no listen we get
this data by the way don't you love it
this is something that people need to
notice too we heard that officer speak
for maybe four seconds yeah yeah we
heard it very it was very respectful and
very peaceful yeah
then they bring in the sound from the
other folks but they they cut in so we
can't hear the officer yeah because no
one hears the officer thing please
listen yeah I have a wife and kids I
want to get home exactly this is a long
night please just move but instead they
show the other guy going y'all can leave
or y'all can stay and that shows up as a
clip revealed though he was not totally
Christmas we all can leave or y'all can
stay really yeah well he's a sweetheart
very nice only they're not allowed to
stay it's closing time because you guys
destroyed [ __ ] for days you don't get to
bed time as earlier now boys and girls
and I believe the mayor of Atlanta isn't
isn't this a black one yes she's a
racist she's man I'm killer Mike to take
the reins all right grab the Bandit are
you there let's make sure we have this
polished up guys right there where you
go yeah I think we're ready to go with
the clip and I think we actually have
more than one club ok can you uh what
are we doing we're not doing them are we
doing the montage right now or no no we
can't I mean we have I gotta cook the
hell or so many and can you tell me how
many officers do I have it right is it
373
injuries to officers that was the tally
as of this afternoon right I know it's
tough to stay abreast especially you
know it's tough for you to keep track
with your peripheral vision that I
didn't get the memo about Vikings so I
feel like I'm appropriating into the
culture right now no no no no
appropriating mid-30s burgling culture
yeah yeah but like the Hamburg I sign
Ninja Turtle but no well you didn't have
to wear the do-rag I wanted you to wear
it you know what Cuckoo's Nest toque but
you know okay show us some footage of
what might happen reg when people don't
respect the
Perimeter let's bring that up oh my gosh
this was vintage moped trying to drag an
officer into the crowd it's the female
officer yeah but they were beautiful
just a moment ago peaceful when they
said we weren't going on about your
we're not gonna respect your perimeter
so they were peaceful but it seems like
it maybe so maybe it devolved really
quickly look at mr. Jimenez or whatever
the hell his name is I forgot what's his
name Nick something Nick's going off
stay in touch with the control room he's
in charge he is very much in charge by
the way my name is Chris quite thank you
crying Chris yeah also mr. CNN is not
obeying the curfew against America yeah
if listen I hate to break ranks with you
sure especially since I'm a high rank
but that's a little strange if if CNN is
not deemed essential but treat him well
but my god he doesn't understand that
says it doesn't happen like a national
treasure if only because I want to see
them tear gas I'm so sorry for you what
was a national treasure
Wade they say everything I do you know
that I want to see CNN get tear-gassed
we talked about it we've talked about it
over cigar at lunch that was the only
thing that pitch meeting I said I hope
if nothing else happens I get to see
someone from CNN tear gas before the end
of my days you know exactly what you
were doing just now you're taking my
dreams way you're stealing that seems
like quite a lot of punishment I just
say I'm sorry and now the police
officers are moving in right they're not
being violent not doing anything wrong
the only walking slowly walking George
you capitalists get everyone when you
say well look white privilege because
you guys brought rivals for the Capitol
and and you know what him you guys
didn't get shot well a couple things
first off concealed carry holders people
who even open carry obey the law more
than police
officers they know that they're safe as
anime B's arms the matter-of-fact of a
police officer pull someone over and he
sees your concealed carry permit
he knows he's less likely to be shot
than somebody who doesn't ii comparing
that with these riots of course we're
never gonna call them protest the
delineating factor there isn't white or
black because there were black people
who run the state capital and there are
white people over here who are who are
protesting the donating factor wasn't
even scary rifles or tactical gear it's
crime it's not a crime to open carry
firearms not even to the state capital
there were no crimes committed look
scary it is illegal to burn down a
building or even to vandalize a building
so it's not a white black thing it's a
crime thing I want to be really clear
because it seems like some people have
gotten that mixed up they try to do the
hypocrisy deal if you just understand
the through line by the way he's Chris
Cuomo question let's go back to reg the
bandit because I think he said he had
another clip of a police officer show us
what happens when people don't honor the
police officers perimeter there reg well
I'm also got an interesting video to
show that the violence has even spread
to London so they've had three lives
matter protest resulted well stop your
season is out and they're looking for
and somebody's got a flop I mean it's
the only thing that proves that they
were rioting in Paris that this is more
disingenuous yeah by the way if police
are brutal in London and in Paris you
can't say it's systemic racism in the
United States and if they're trying to
protest for systemic racism the United
States by the way ten men shot last year
Danna I don't black men knows you
deserve the 10 is not genocide then
they're just looking for a reason to
write to try and put one over the United
States in an absurd bar say is so you're
saying that more people have died in
this week of protests than times last
year days than any unarmed black men
from police officer Wow there's more
white people killed less but no we don't
that doesn't matter it really doesn't if
you keep bringing that up I'm gonna say
something yeah well you know
hands over here yeah that's right by the
way like I said it's an r-rating tonight
I want to be very clear because we're
gonna be showing some footage but you
know obviously the hashtag that has been
coming dear by black activists who share
very little in common with the actual
black community you know it's black
lives matter no you know the hashtags
been given to white people Oh has it
luckily oh wow let's go catch you bandit
yeah show us your tell us what is that
you have here so this is from yesterday
in London hmm they ran out of Guinness
that's really a get in there I have to
say those police officers look woefully
ill-equipped yes bring up my billy club
and we're gonna have to make a call to
the truancy officers seems to me that
you're not in your schooling facilities
that's not nice alright this doesn't
look good Wow
so yes that's what happens in London we
peaceful these protests they were
actually just happy that the soccer
season was going to be restarted yeah so
that's just got a little you know hockey
in Canada something like that Hockey
Night in Canada is there anything that
we missed here reg while we're watching
CNN because again the real value of
course last time as we pulled up so much
from Twitter but I know they might not
get wild and wooly until the lights go
down yeah so it's been a little more
toned down fortunately so far this
evening in DC there's heavy rain and
storm yeah that's pretty good possibly
this comes right right perfect
so that's good at the very least far
left anarchists are lazy I can't get wet
the ring they call the Crowder confronts
where we were going to confront that guy
and then there was a few drops of rain
oh yeah yeah that was the guy at the
beer garden right yeah yes that's right
I remember Johnny boy he was one who set
that up and he said he said beer garden
nice the revolution has to be paused
guys no more tonight you might get wet
and ruin the nobody wants that title
just go out there with super soakers to
mom yeah exactly it's the most entitled
group of rioters that I think we've ever
seen
alright keep us abreast you're in and
Reggie Bennett just bring in at any
point whenever you see something that
you can let us know let's go right now
to CNN that's Chris Cuomo sound coming
from mr. Flores direction everyone wait
is going P okay P P wait beam your
helmet be a man started mr. flower
Floyd myself and maybe even a poet
depart no the officer tempo will be
coming up later on this evening and we
have a big surprise one that goes bang
bang bang cuckoo
really I'm happy about it partner was oh
my brother said I believe using a
use-of-force situation so the officers
came up to both sides of the vehicle
asking for ID what happened on George's
side of the vehicle that made the
officers run after their do you know
over there do you remember I do
I remember hearing aloud like the object
of a blunt force some large object
whatever the officer had in his hand
again I'm turned because I'm taking care
the officer that's on my side I can only
hear this and once I hear this is lawyer
strikes I don't know but she's asked to
try he's quite fetching but he's very
looking woman hey nice catch by the way
proves that I'm not racist
no I don't mean ice here Dylan so he's
asking girls tight wasn't saying get
away from the car leave me alone
I'm not gonna get out nothing like that
oh he was kind of whining can we can we
check has CNN ever brought on any of the
officers or their friends this is a guy
who I mean his qualifications not even
fit longtime friend he was that he had a
passing qualifications of stars and
printed on his shirt yes yeah yes by the
way I'm just checking in have we seen
actual evidence of racism I know it was
a white police officer and a black
suspect but have we actually seen bad
cop yeah you know that's and this is the
problems when you feel good I've got
issue that is fabricated by the media
you lose sight of the bigger issue which
is poor police training which is a
militarized police state which is one
that frankly is supposed to serve and
protect but a lot of police officers not
all think that they are there to control
us that is an issue that every person
black white could be on board with if
that was if these were the chance right
now at the riots you would have rednecks
out there with you who want their stuff
to not be disturbed by police officers
right exactly
don't want to submit themselves to
unwarranted search and seizures instead
they turned it into a racial issue just
like it was Mike Brown now and the
difference in error there this guy
wasn't actually reaching and punching
right but the cop could be a bad cop
right now he met in the car racist not
every single action of black on white
anything is racism it's not it could not
get me one today
well Maxine what information do you have
that the rest of the country seems not
to have that makes you think that that's
true
no in this persona day she was talking
about Duncan oh I thought it was the
coffee she likes her thing a mean
bearclaw
I miss national donut day I miss
national again I think you get free year
a they say it's every day well if it's
in your heart well and now my heart's a
whole
[Laughter]
all right I got Stinson [ __ ] by the way
I took Joey what's up dad it's not like
street work on the show more no I sent
him the video of the Korean shopkeeper
yes yes yeah yeah and he was laughing so
hard so hard because his dad was his dad
experienced that in lawsuit I think his
dad was in Los Angeles but his dad was
in the war but didn't want to have a gun
and he talked about this was so you know
they're mean we've got Koreans yeah yeah
and he talkin about how the leader in
Koreatown in Los Angeles during the Los
Angeles Riots actually went out on his
homemade radios it's very difficult very
expensive was on for 24 hours he went oh
wow hey the police will come to protect
you do not purchase firearms don't go
out there and be a hero and then the
next day he said well no police are
showing up so it's some difference so
the guy who created it that movement of
rooftop Koreans initially got on the
radio to tell people all is well wait
for the cops and as only when they were
getting ransacked and abused and by the
way hate crimes committed hey yeah yeah
they were blaming them for a lot of the
economic problems that they were having
that Koreans had moved into the
neighborhood and stolen jobs and started
businesses and it's like well they
showed a little initiative and now
you're pissed off at them they can't get
a chance you have all the Kim Zhang's
and then you have the Los Angeles Riots
and then they make falling down with the
Korean shopkeepers yeah he's the villain
right off the bat because he's
overcharging for coke which by the way
is not entirely inaccurate I will say
Korean shopkeepers they tend to up
charge when it comes to soda but I'll
pay it yeah I will pay it because it's
good he's a South Korean not a North
Korean be nice to him yeah I don't care
either way someone's getting an Uzi in
the face Wow
they make this so knots with me from the
Korean let's show this clip because then
we later we have a montage of all the
worst crimes have been committed and
then we have the isolated yeah and you
know it's crazy once the Sun Goes Down
on
right we'll show that later later on the
show I want to be very clear - we have a
real I guess you would sit on a
highlight a low-light real yeah all the
violence that's been committed here
during these riots as they continue to
try and say that this is peaceful then
after that though couldn't stay with us
because after that we have a highlight
reel let's draw of
all the hipsters and protesters getting
their asses yeah oh so you know little
submitter has all T all right you take
the good with little low well high and I
think we have a palate cleanser in there
of a 7 + 1 7 + 1 excuses for what is it
when caught looting yeah like a fine
sorbet what is going on he's just
waiting for an opportunity to say his
name he leaned in yeah she's an attorney
oh that's what Chris Cuomo was talking
about yeah now our question for you miss
sideshow missus such a major way to
becoming president of the n-double a-c-p
were you afraid they would find out
about your race in actuality he was
doing a piece on I started with sales
for Chico I think I'm actually a lot
funnier when I have a beer in me so to
the part of to the team to say yeah yeah
you're G's whether job always have a
beer you man you know my client tell you
he said you know I've been hurt before
please what is this about right so crap
so here's my question so you wonders we
always have footage there and then we
have you have to give him on the ground
why don't we have footage of an between
the gun between ground or the officers
have body cams right so where's that
booze
yeah and that could either be a problem
with police acting more brutally and
taking off their body cam right or it
could be something that they don't
necessarily want to show us because
thank you bear way yeah that's which is
what was reported
we can't know oh thank you for him oh
sorry yeah looks like yeah it looks like
the camera do you have that ain't hard
for me with these amulets to you
what are these for is it swords like so
you don't get like cut yeah both chewing
or is it to block the rain if you're a
protester and it rains thanks also hard
you know it's like this you don't want
condensation so there's some auto ship
around now they show them lifting him up
right okay he's up so I am interested
then he went into the police car right
George Floyd yeah police car and by the
way everyone who's watching
they just set up the perimeter so god
forbid it gets well we know it's going
to get probably a matter the lower level
of violence than we've seen the last few
nights bo and we're hitting curfew times
to typically when people are starting to
get a little more frisky and that's why
they're doing pieces with you know
George qualifications CNN longtime
contributors friend okay there you go
okay and what that's him they're pulling
him out of that car right they don't
have installs they don't have it tucked
here I don't think right maybe they do
maybe they have his other arm anyone
seen the footage of between him in the
car - out on the ground no because
that's the portion of the report where
they said he was getting unruly not
saying it's true but it is a piece of
information that I would like to know
I'm always curious as to why we have 12
different angles of one part of any
angle of the most pivotal part right I
found I found the body cam footage but
it's heavily redacted oh I believe
whatever mind and if nobody would
actually redact it and that movie sucked
it did redacted renditions Lions for
lambs those are all
try to you know vilify our troops and
right now we're vilifying our police
sensors by the way to everyone out there
I stopped today and I just thank the
police officer right near you know where
that new 7-eleven is yeah I just pulled
over I said and I'm always very careful
because I pull over tonight what huh hey
it's not a threat I got answers I've
been getting a lot of flack and I just
want to thank you and he he's a man
thank thank you so much I really
appreciate he kind of got choked up and
asked him if he was paying attention at
all to the meeting he said you know what
I've just shut it all off I don't watch
Han you have to or on any side and you
know what you don't want that you don't
want a cop right who can't watch any
media because of the constant
vilification thread you want an officer
like a Darren Wilson who asked to serve
in Ferguson you want an auditor who was
in tune with his community
who's in touch who wasn't as informed as
possible you don't want them to isolate
themselves but what choice do they have
what how do you think you if you right
now tuned into the television Chris
Cuomo he is Chris coma you tune into
Chris coma and you knew that without
fail they would be vilifying you
directly or by proxy every hour of the
day you personally you think you'd shut
off the news look that's what police
officers are doing you want this you
want some kind of a feedback capability
here well don't turn don't make it to
the point where police officers can't
even tune into television and police
officers can't even peacefully request
that people acknowledge a police
perimeter lines that they can save women
and children and burning buildings you
do that you shut off the dialogue just
like Seth Rogen if you don't you don't
think black lives matter you all should
stop follow me you don't deserve my
movies I'm not waiting on the interview
too but no I don't think so you know
what happens I want the opposite of that
we talked about that on Good Morning
Mudd Club if I say something you
disagree with let me know maybe maybe
I'm wrong maybe you can help correct me
I know a lot of people didn't like the
fact that I talked about George Floyd's
crime of jamming a loaded pistol into a
pregnant woman's belly and pistol
whipping her and I don't think that that
changed the fact that he should not have
died at the hands of the officer right
but I do think when you're using him as
an emblem and painting him on walls I do
think that you should in other words of
shape yes there should be information we
were wrongfully killed by a police
officer in the bunker and I'm not saying
George Floyd was Hitler but he you know
what
I put it on a level of evil putting a
loaded pistol in the belly of a pregnant
woman that's pretty evil you know what I
think it's actually compares as far as
evil Hitler evil putting a pistol anyone
who's ever had a kid anyone's a very
pregnant wife just imagine someone
putting a loaded pistol with five other
guys to your wife's belly do we really
think that's someone who should be
representative of George Floyd is all of
us really know all of you have I hope
knives loaded pistols into women's
villas into your god I hope it wasn't a
Walther oh no it wouldn't be I don't
think it would have been to walk in a
Taurus having something like that it's
probably a Beretta High Point or Caltech
let's brick let's have three lawsuits
well but seriously when it comes to I
want to be very clear about this if you
care about the people around you while
we're talking about these violent crimes
and boundaries that you should respect
yeah friends do not let friends buy high
points you don't and not count on them
let's yeah if we're only clear about one
thing tonight it's gonna be that yes
well and you know Richmond cheat nah
that's your offer well and I don't think
this really I mean facts are always
relevant right in this case like the
facts of who the people are right is the
officer somebody who's had complaints
against them or not have a stellar
record right it's tough yeah I can't
grab your beer you have to get it off
then right or you know is this person
somebody who's been violent towards
police before have they interacted
before all of these things are relevant
I don't think that we would be focusing
quite as much on the fact this guy has a
rap sheet that it's terribly long unless
everybody else in the media was trying
to make him out to be a saint right
right this guy and I tweeted this out
earlier today because people were saying
like he was known as a man who would
stand up for his friends and family and
I'm like okay well that's fine his life
his death was a crime right I think we
all agree on yeah his death was a crime
his life was much the same a series of
crimes that he committed right let's not
make him out to be a saint just because
his death was a crime who can admit that
this was a generally bad guy who ended
up getting killed in an illegal way well
and that's fine and we're gonna go to
some more some highlights here and reg
the Bandit please do let us know if
we're missing anything but here is
something that is important should not
have died from that police officer want
to be really clear eight that every
single time
however they did work at the same club
right we know that they weren't in the
same club I didn't know that yeah they
were the same nightclub purity we don't
necessarily know that they know each
other one on the inside outside do five
years for that crime and other crimes
that he committed right um so a good
chance that this guy knows who George
Floyd was right there's a good chance of
that and then for sure if he runs the
plates that's why they run the plates
what's waiting for me in this car right
so let me ask you this if you're a
police officer and I'm not saying that
you should have kept his knee on the
neck I cannot be more clear but can you
understand how you might handle a
scenario differently when you run the
plates and go oh my god
six five to fit well how tall was this
guy six five to fifty was something like
that big dude big dude at least two and
a quarter at least six four I've seen as
high as six six I've seen as low as six
four you can see in the tape let's say
six five to thirty you run the place you
go oh my gosh
six five to thirty did five years for
jamming a loaded gun into a pregnant
woman's stomach and has had offenses
since then armed assault I'm not gonna
take any chances as a police officer and
my point is that can escalate a scenario
that had wrongfully so because the
officer should know how to de-escalate
it but it may not have anything to do
with race do you think that officer if
he pulls over a toothless meth head from
Salem's Lot needs to trailer Alma's over
from Eminem do you think it because oh
my gosh this guy knocked up a liquor
store and pistol-whipped a small child
and beat his wife and he said drug
offenses since then I'm gonna handle
this differently than I'm going to
handle let's say your wife in a pullover
yeah it doesn't mean the top is racist
cops get scared too they want to go home
at the end of the day right very
situation to go into they have no clue
what's going on what's gonna happen and
they have to think about that all the
time so think about being on edge like
that every situation you know many times
police officers have walked up to the
side of a car to give somebody a
speeding ticket and have been blown away
right right it is ingrained in them that
your life is on the line every single
time you interact with somebody and
that's a different thing than me sitting
here going oh well I probably wouldn't
have done that well no my life people
know that CNN is up there even though
they're doing puff pieces that no one
cares about
exactly yeah he's really mad right now
that his name is not being said more
Chris Palmer I can see it in his eyes
he's like if I could just work it out in
there that's better guys better wrong he
just pooped is reg the Bandit there and
there is there anything that we've
missed or anything going on reg that we
said should on which we should stay
abreast so I do have an update on
Twitter's handling a back checking in
regards to the black life it should be
interesting okay well someone just to be
clear by the way someone repeatedly
attempted to docks us these last couple
days right we hosted the wrong address
but it still pissed me off
well yes times in a row it took over 30
hours for Twitter to do anything
look the Tastee Freez but they did
verify my tweet saying that if you Neal
you're a [ __ ] within 14 minutes oh wow
doxing not that big of a concern over
there Twitter because I don't want even
though it's not our dress I don't want
the person in that address to have
someone show up and try and blow them
away
so sorry go ahead and update us there
Reggie so a day or two ago oh there was
this claim just spreading like wildfire
on Twitter that then you're at least had
shot a 13 year old boy 19 times and you
know it turned out up now we know it was
30 year old man 34 year old man who had
a gun and had already shot somebody ah
now I just could say and there any blue
check that still have the tweets up are
they at all verified no no back check at
all and I mean I think that really
Stokes violence toward the police
because I mean sure if you actually
thought police were out shooting 13 year
olds 19 times I mean yeah you'd be angry
yeah right yeah of course but that would
be morally reprehensible and those
police officers if they were shooting an
unarmed 13 year old nine times whoo 19
times wasn't doing it wrong they should
receive the same penalty as a
perpetrator if the state allows the
death penalty that's what they should
get so yeah I mean that's the context
now the breaking news that I have here
is that trumpet posted a tribute to
George Floyd I
the Trump campaign - posted a video
Branko saying that there's just epi
twitter has just taken it down well what
a copier
Wow now you've been asked for comment
and you know who planed copyright on
this video they said they can't comment
on it they have to have the virus there
several media organizations contacted
them no feedback on it do we know do we
have the ability to find the clip
regi ban anything you can find it
somewhere else on some type of
contraband website I know you sometimes
see others of the proton dark web maybe
there was a Nickelback song but yeah in
which case the between rights of nickel
music from Nickelback supersedes the
justice for George Floyd provided that
Donald Trump is one tweeting I don't
think George Floyd tribute that wasn't a
gross copyright infringement made on
Windows Movie Maker yeah I don't even
know that was still around no every
single tribute I've seen is you know
either Tupac or tattoo singing with like
that little star transition of his
headshot well just a nice screen printed
t-shirt somebody's making money on the
shirts capitalist among you I see how
this guy want a socialist revolution but
until they went until finally police
socialist revolution but until that
happens you put a little mspaint to work
okay all right earlier we're talking
about sort of like reputations and I
think that the the media has every
incentive to call all of their I was
just feeling to see if my helmet I was
great it's missing something wait I
can't mystery yeah so what the media has
every incentive to call all of the
friends and say will you describe him as
a great father like would you describe
him as a wonderful friend and man like
no they're not gonna go out and find the
people who say negative things about
these guys they have to find positive
things so that you can think this guy is
bad this guy's Jesus Christ might be too
far
[Laughter]
I don't know what's going on what is it
you have to take it off a flag if you
want the bridge they'll be back here why
can't you what's right dressed as a draw
what I'm wondering is why I if I saw a
boat full of these guys I wouldn't be
very intimidated honor their perimeter
yeah it looks really scary mussels but I
think the axe is you know a balance yeah
I think it just makes you pause on my
pointy tits too late I'm seeing him
coming in right now
i watch the on the payoffs the guy
habits whatever the pay law itself has
seemed destroyed he was kind of a bully
and I sure was it o-o okay so right now
this is just to be clear for people who
are just tuning in again the hashtag is
Crowder riot streamwriter Xcode is
Viking you get $20 off but just update
people or tuning in Donald Trump posted
a tribute to George Floyd Twitter
removed it for copyright even though
they're not fact-checking any of the
misinformation other yeah and like real
for attempted daxing you know has ever
however inaccurate it may be against
ourselves they did remove this tribute
to George Floyd posted by Donald Trump
all right reg the Beast
take it away sir do it
I understand the pain that people are
feeling the death of George Floyd on the
streets of Minneapolis was a grave
tragedy it should never have happened it
has failed Americans all over the
country with horror anger and grief we
support the right of peaceful protesters
and we hear their pleas the voices of
law-abiding citizens must be heard and
heard very loudly
I understand with the family of George
murder with the peaceful protesters and
with every law-abiding citizen what's
decency civility she say is it the music
and so yeah that's the only thing to
take what we are sitting on it's like in
red it's nothing to do with justice or
with mace the memory of George Floyd is
being dishonored by rioters looters and
anarchists good message and vandalism is
being led by an Tifa and other radical
left-wing groups who are terrorizing the
innocent destroying jobs but no
reasoning the mobs are devastating the
life's work of good people and
destroying their traces as presidential
as one community soars
it harms those who have the least we
cannot and must not allow a small group
of criminals and vandals to wreck our
cities and lay waste to our communities
we must defend the rights of every
citizen to live without violence
prejudice or fear healing not hatred
justice not chaos are the mission and
I stand before you as a friend and Ally
to every American seeking justice and
peace no one is more upset than fellow
law enforcement officers by the small
handful who failed tours a lot by their
local media here too sir not just
bluster and we support campaigning well
a big majority of police officers who
are incredible in every way and devoted
public servants we must all work
together as a society
to expand opportunity and to create a
future of greater dignity and promise
for all of our people
every citizen in every community has the
right to be safe in their workplace safe
in their homes and safe in our city
streets we are working toward a more
just society but that means building up
not tearing down joining hands not
hurling firsts standing in solidarity
not surrendering to hostility this is
the sacred right of all Americans that I
am totally determined to defend and will
defend
okay pause real quick Reggie I want to
go back to you Chris Cuomo looks like
he's on a rant being shitty let's see
what he's saying take so long George
Floyd was a big guy wasn't Shaq okay you
know the idea he can't fit in a car
doesn't make sense he was in a car he
was in a kite it's like the only person
it would be clearly I think because most
be like he makes you look small does why
back up why on the ground why in the
cruiser why back on the ground why so
much time this is what has to be
answered in this prosecute ring I know
the law demands where's your Booker
credit the rest of the video though what
about the rest of this yeah where's your
why don't we have answers I didn't hear
you ask for any answers right didn't
hear you bring anyone on who would be
qualified to give answers I heard you
bring somebody on who claims he was in
the SUV and was a longtime friend of
George Floyd why don't you bring on
people who can answer why don't you
demand footage that would provide
answers but we understand he's not shaq
no he's more the size of a Hakeem
Olajuwon if he had a little bit more
weight on a little bit yeah yeah so what
was the reason they banned that for
Trump reg the Bandit that we just saw
that video what was their reasoning so
again they haven't given any reasoning
they've been reached for comment by
several news organizations and they said
they wouldn't discuss it without a group
of lawyers there but I think it's worth
nobody that it hasn't been hip for a
copy strike on YouTube right and I think
we can sort of see why Twitter might
want to take down this message called
Yahoo peace and cooperation and then
leave up something saying that NYPD is
shooting 13 year olds 19 times right
right we have a vested interest in you
know Jack Dorsey is very good friends
with Gregg McKesson and other members
black life better have the best interest
seeing these continued DeRay McKesson
the guy who was so racist keep in mind
that when he watched Planet of the Apes
rise of the Apes and he saw one of the
Apes all of whom were in human clothing
and one of them had a blue vest he sued
for cop for trademark infringement
because he assumed that it was meant to
look like him he saw himself
the story just got in google DeRay
Planet of the Apes I would never in my
wildest dreams have made that connection
ya know before I went I only went to see
the movie because DeRay complain where
he was like clearly look they put an ape
in a blue vest and it looks like me
dressers but this must be a joke to rent
a theater here eh did ray-ray not derail
does this careers too stupid it's out
there you know that they're sympathetic
obviously to people like DeRay and then
I see this one sort of thin less strong
aid and like if I'd have known about
leaders back then I would have requested
one I was like what seeing in a film
seeing someone dressed in a giant actual
sphincter [ __ ] costume and me being
like I am my likeness
[Laughter]
yes go ahead
think we have a shot of Geraci himself
in the plant of age do we bring it up
all right yeah let's bring it up when
you have it because the reason he's
doing this is because Steven can get in
trouble if he's saying DeRay Apes I
brought it in here eh said it DeRay I
think he fart on the deal so let me know
when reg had in the clip it was so funny
when I watched it because I'm going to
us
Oh God you got it okay all right all
right let's bring this up oh I see what
you did
maybe we should stay in our lane bro all
right let's see the actual image of it
you know at the local cinema or Lowe's
sitting there watching it and he sees a
skinny unattractive ape in a blue vest I
like to think that he gets a check every
month from the Funko pop because we all
feel like we have to clarify ignore no
he's saying yeah DeRay said it if
someone wants to take this out of
context please do senator Aryan make
sure she you know gets her reading
glasses on above that new honker that
she purchased and I am more than happy
to go to arms with people who want to
take this out of context I think it's so
funny it's an array made the assumption
that's me that the ape was him I mean
for crying out loud
what do you just go just go to REI tens
of North faces out there just like that
exactly by the way say this reg that
that was Prior I don't know much what
you guys think but that was one of the
most powerful videos that I have seen
regard not a force we can let that
Donald Trump from anyone make I was
saying this right that's one of those
powerful videos why in the world because
what it made me think was like okay
maybe we can get through this maybe we
can unify maybe we can get past riding a
band and it's going hey Twitter why you
have to answer this question why every
you have a visitor don't wait for your
lawyers really have some balls in answer
let's see what Chris Cuomo this is Chris
Cuomo has to say Robles imagine to have
been that he was referring it serious
but he was run down oh this is the
memory as he lay dying his accused
killer reportedly spewed hate that takes
this directly to what it was most feared
to be about even the investor so dynamic
we heard a report from someone i'm chris
cuomo that's thank you for being the
person who committed murder who use
worst of all a special her have used the
n-word black piece and what do you think
about a man using the n-word who killed
a black guy I think it's bad I'm Chris
Cuomo we'll be back after this thank you
very poignant very poignant you but I
would also hope that black people who
have children who have wives who have
husbands who want them to come home
probably more upset about if it's murder
with the murdering yeah yeah yeah
afterwards part of the problem this is
why this matters okay because they tried
to justify that footage that we showed
earlier with Scurlock they tried to
justify the man mounted and beated
beaten repeatedly because they said he
said the n-word
now all independent III witnesses aside
from one person said no that wasn't the
case they also claimed and I don't know
if this is true even if even if it
doesn't someone the woman who was beaten
with two-by-fours while they made her
husband watch their guys one of them the
one with too much force they claimed
that after the first strike with a
two-by-four
she called him the N word after the
first one I guess he dies now she said
she said to me word it doesn't matter
you don't get to commit violent crimes
I get that no one should say the N word
I've heard the N word one time in my
life he's untier on ik Lee everyone
knows the story was in a Bob Evans
restaurant and my heart never stopped
that's where people go to use the n-word
are far from anything I go there Bob
they always go for the breakfast and
also to get some decently priced
pancakes I mean where the ponytail
thingies whatever those are all right so
all right well thank you retro and
you're something that also really
matters with Donald Trump then removing
that on Twitter again they removed that
sand crab salutely because they kept up
hate mongering about the NYPD firing on
a 13 year old who was 19 years old
indiscriminately we know that's not true
that in fact check out they didn't move
people at something to docs us but they
did remove Donald Trump's video that
touched on love not hate hugs not
clenched fists nobody is more upset than
our police officers and we need to
support our good good police officers a
call for unity they removed it for
copyright now that may or may not be
true may be one of those images like I'm
not sure if Donald Trump again really a
deputy Getty or shutterstock Lee let's
get e is it shutter stuck I never shut
it okay steady as a rock and stuck I'm
more of a bond guy stock have you ever
heard of steady hedge fund but right now
you can find a thousands of profiles
that have the same footage and some of
them are using completely blatantly
copyrighted copyrighted music and they
are not being taken down so this is what
matters with social media when people
said well you know Donald Trump said he
said voting ballots one of did that
ballot submissions that's incorrect
it's not about there being a rule on
Twitter or on youtube or on Facebook
it's about the rule or the law being
applied equally Oh equal justice it
seems like this is a trend right now I
don't know why but I think I've heard
that before
yeah it's a trend until the rioting
starts well that's now going on right
now have to take a potty break and I
know that we have Tim Poole and not
super how long is that first montage of
all the violence and destruction the
first one is one one minute and 40
seconds one minute and forty ones two
movies okay all right so then now let me
do this I want it now I want to warn
everybody out there again the promo code
is Viking you get $20 off the hash -
what are you doing on your phone yes sir
okay no don't do it
yeah I will put an actual Jo the hashtag
is Crowder and your tights put it over
there right now
no please okay let's register this is a
union shop you see that red shift that
long shot of his tights get that long
shot of the chain mode they don't feel
bad you don't ice big penis they're so
big I want to show everyone this and I
want you to stay with us because what
you're about to watch is very difficult
to watch because the media is going to
be talking about how these protests are
peaceful and we just saw them just not
refusing to honor sorry the the police
perimeter line yeah but I want you to
see what's been going on since last
Saturday yep just since we last streamed
while there was violence going on that
night but stay with us because after
this I know it's hard to stomach we will
have a highlight reel of people and
police officers fighting back and so
before that just remember this when they
say these have been largely peaceful
protests you're talking single digit
percentages of cities that haven't
erupted in violence mainly very very
small protests in the suburbs like
places in Frisco where they did a margin
yeah Frisco doesn't play like that
outside of that violence has erupted
everywhere what kind of violence well
watch for yourself oh come on over TV
car over TV pop him cuz he gone bro he
gone bro I was a TVs cuz
there's less anger and then you come
12
[Music]
was that guy yelling I've got your dog
it wasn't his dog didn't look like it
was his dog either way someone's that
dog away from him yes
was that the footage of the guy that was
abusing a dog on the news did you see
that no I don't yeah he was holding the
dog but you can do it by its scruff yeah
he was like shaking it around and stuff
well that was just did you not see a
couple of things really quickly we're
going to show the highlight clip -
because let not your heart be troubled
right um but something that I've noticed
that obviously important Chris Cuomo has
spent no time on the ground no the one
time here on the ground we heard
everyone here heard what sounded like
mortar shells going off right everyone
her son was going down right everyone
hurt the Sun was going down then we
heard the police saying please honor
this perimeter and one guy said
blacklivesmatter don't curfew at nine
o'clock and then they got into each
other's faces right they have not gone
back to the street at all so official
dream seems a little less dynamic it's
because for some reason CNN doesn't want
us to know what is going on in the
street how long they're on Brady nettles
now 28 minutes where they haven't gone
to the streets that's what's going on in
the street now we are going to show you
really quickly a highlight reel and then
we're going to go into a quick break so
that I can go drop the debate
so um there have been a lot of peaking
Senate fought back and and police
officers I don't mean vigilantism I mean
people who have of course defended
themselves defended their property and
yes police officers who have had enough
of watching their I mean the trick of
this number right 373 fellow offers
officers being taken to the ICU
over 400 probably serious injuries to
police officers of course over a dozen
people dead from last night we don't
know what the numbers are so even though
I know it's upsetting I would like you
to enjoy the highlight of every
good that's happened he had a nice pic
and he was feeling free world's
permission
baby native thank you turning to crap
driveway hope is doing all right yeah
swinging that Slugger like he's Babe
Ruth
I hope he doesn't miss that she's no
bees do
disintegration day to be
hipster pepper-sprayed in his eyes you
know that you might be gone for good if
you try
labor
the queers
Dana said but Stephen darling
tear gassing at Trump on the phone
right
[Applause]
and so staring at me I think that I'm
embarrassed out there to you Lord that
getting it up tonight
empty [ __ ] guys are not doing well here
they're all Jewish speaking Garvey
[Applause]
I was gonna treat you like a walker [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't number you cancel with this
you rock
[Music]
[Music]
black rifle cook buffet Oh
a thing okay folks frankly it's the best
coffee out there
ar-15 coffee m16 coffee it's a coffee
with bazooka Bazooka Joe - coffee look
at the BRIT can we get the hero shot
today still make Bazooka Joe he used to
be a petty rifle of color coffee this
coffee should be dating a Kardashian
okay this coffee is the best coffee
black rifle coffee and unlike other
companies who claim small batch your
premium black rifle coffee is it roasted
frankly until you place your order
making sure it's the freshest coffee
many people don't know it's a it's a
beat it goes bad coffee go to black
rifle coffee dot-com slash Crowder enter
the promo code Crowder to receive 20%
off your first order of black rifle
coffee okay great
simple give me a diet coke louder with
prouder shop comm is now selling
baseball team in red blue and ash get
yours at ladder with quite a shop gum
today
all right yes yeah yeah so well he goes
back right yeah right yeah thank you
very much well we have some costumes so
it turns out some of you actually did
have yeah we see the horse all right
there we go we have another winner but I
don't know if that's the winner
hey let me Johnny Mathis I'm saying on a
did the tinfoil hat guy would win he's
agreed to hear a ding to friends about
the George Floyd case and it's not like
we're some high percentage a news I
don't even my kids only watch this do
90% of the time it is it was so long
it's so wrong so long and it's so
frightening this is who Elmo can't even
go through the full Windsor no we have a
cigar fan in the office I mean just
immediately not hello how you doing
nothing I have so many of those phone
calls that just well my hair needs me
hold on I can't do the dunk good way
[Laughter]
don't do the long hair might ruin the
illusion that that stands really it's
like a drag I don't know what I can say
anymore about that but they pulled their
wig off yeah hey not good
oh my gosh why what's in her stomach
0% because like a little drama that's
why you shouldn't have lady yeah I don't
want to see female cops dark helmet
yeah it's not fair Elmo is Crowder riot
stream Viking you get $20 off we have
team poco and Minnes viper do what I say
promo codes I said it was the the
hashtag is credit right stream what yeah
promos hey why'd I stop huh huh huh what
huh 24 $20 off cuomo is now happy
because somebody probably said his name
Oh Oh Don Lemon okay oh that's right we
do have one more thing because the last
clip and that was the rooftop Korean yes
yes the yeah you don't want to say but
here's the rooftop Koreans are a mean
obviously because true made their stuff
they were abandoned by the LAPD and
they're often the victim of hate crimes
to get true and everyone was obviously
laughing at him you know right but yes
he's here here when he was like you you
you mother you have all this [ __ ] coming
up like yeah so the thing is good
American protecting his stuff yeah
doesn't necessarily have a mastery of
the English language
you have it so that clip actually
continued what's that going on Tim do
you have it we have that we have the
audio bump we don't have an actual clip
oh we don't have that follow up so we
have we have the extended version with
the extra on it I believe I
misunderstood yeah okay well then we'll
have to go that's why your name is audio
way to not video wait right I'm the
worst what happened all right oh that's
okay so someone will be suspended with
pay which really isn't that much of a
pun it's like a vacation you know what
the rioters at some point one of you
guys is getting to your guests
let's bring I bought your way see what's
going on and then reg the bandits I hope
you have something for us because it
looks like things are getting wild and
wooly again Lord a peaceful protest
largely and of course it's New York
police officers of course me on his neck
he died don't you love how that black
guy in that Deep Ellum said like you
know when they call in a crime and they
say in the news they say black they say
black people don't say white I've just
ever John lemon say white more times
again he could take a single breath
fifty times because they want division
right use that as a descriptor there it
is breeding division and that's what
they want because that's what they think
some kind of progress comes from is
right is dissension in chaos also he
says the fantasy parts out loud yeah so
let's see let's listen to dawn limo
lives people of color the president
apparently couldn't even be bothered to
tweet about it wow wow alright someone
everyone for the game this is for me
this is why we need the executive order
on social media yes this is why we need
to have some clear-cut boundaries
because guess what god I guarantee you
Jack Dorsey has spoken with Zucker and
Cuomo and Don Lemon I guarantee you he
has more of an inn than certainly Donald
Trump or any conservative with social
media so either Don Lemon with his many
many tens of millions of dollars in
budget I don't even know what his salary
is but this at least at least 50
producers and staff probably over 100
minimum there couldn't be bothered to
know that
Trump posted that tribute that we just
talked about which was complete right
it was truthfully very beautiful I keep
yeah and truthfully because I'm
president Trump thank you I sorry I said
mister please don't have me to audit it
okay I just meant to say president I was
just speaking really quickly and Don
Lemon has me all we-we'd up he either
doesn't have the ability to do research
and we're supposed to believe that he
doesn't know Donald Trump put that out
there that long video that took a lot of
work to put together or he knows and
he's complicit me saying that Donald
Trump couldn't take any time out of his
day that is a lie when we talk about
fake news media that is a that's an
absolute lie because Donald Trump has
commented from the get-go on George yeah
from the get-go and has gone to great
lengths to make sure that we know where
he stands
you don't care Don you don't care just
don't care you don't want to tell the
truth how do you think destroyer would
work if he said and the president to his
credit of course condemned the the the
Senate has killed hold for you George
Floyd and did upload this video that was
a very long recalled for hugs and not
clenched fists and said that we are
stronger together but it was removed for
copyright that might change the story
now take that and times that every
minute of every hour of every day and
that's what you get with CNN yeah are
you guys watching is everyone out there
watching Don Lemon just said that Donald
Trump didn't have enough time to take
out of his day to comment on George
Floyd we just showed you the video
tribute that was taken down from Twitter
they're like Raptors communicating and
coordinating and triangulating to try
and take people out Twitter says all
right listen we're not gonna fact-check
not gonna fact-check the vicious rumor
that NYPD officers killed a 13 year old
by shooting him 19 times I was actually
have 30 something year old and they
actually haven't shoots under in the
unarmed suspect that's not true we're
not gonna fact-check that we're gonna
leave that up on every single celebrity
profile but we are going to move donald
trump's video tribute to George Floyd
where he calls it senseless and calls
for better training of police officers
and unity and then you guys just run the
stories it will yeah and the only thing
they're gonna say right now in Don's
take is something about Trump and paint
it as him not respond
your Trump's and just aggressions about
police violence yeah exactly will it
include that video cuz no it probably
will all you know all he said before
volume then made a speech it was a
speech about the rocket and I devoted at
25 percent of the speech probably to
what happened or more - what happened
with respect to the George your
exploited speech about a rocket
are you mad done wasn't a speech about
George Floyd or do you miss now ism or
how African Americans are treated by
police definitely miss that was totally
missed it by the way drink rocket
african-americans treated by police so
yeah yeah nineteen white guys shot last
year on on white guys by police
yeah unarmed black men just to be really
clear and most of them both the white
and black guys deserved it not exactly
genocide when you add it all up all
races twenty-nine go ahead with so why
did see why i CN n reporting on every
other Trump tweet right isn't that the
entire programming slant is Trump tweets
but oh we can't do that one except said
it yeah and keep in mind let's assume
maybe they couldn't get it because it
was removed okay we have a guy in a Burt
Ward mask who got it within 30 seconds
you can't be bothered with that Don them
all but by the way do you guys
understand how unifying the SpaceX
launch was to people how much hope it
gave people totally overlooked a leader
can go and say hey guys this is a really
great event that we came together and
did look at this we're going back into
space with this public-private
partnership and it's fantastic and he
said I devoted 25 percent of my speech
to George Ford what else do you want and
yeah in his Don Lemon mad at Walter
Cronkite for not commenting on all the
racial injustice when the man I handed
on the moon yeah rocket should be coming
and why is he looking increasingly like
an old lady who would pay you in
quarters to rake her yard
it looks like agents like age makeup
does there's probably there's probably
an AIDS component I'm not saying but you
know major aids what he's saying cuz
this guy is just I used to say that he
seemed more reasonable with the horse
now died lemon oh here we go
apparently he has the Widmer Widmer sign
language artist without her without his
wig on and we were coming up 57th Street
we were coming up and down we were
walking around and then for whatever
reason yes we're two hours past the
curfew for what every skin passes yeah
group of protesters move north on Fifth
Avenue officers just started moving in
and making arrests for no reason because
they're breaking yeah whew this be
related to earlier no please stay back
cuz keep in mind look what do you see
the mobs in the street no there have
been women and children caught in fires
who couldn't be saved by fire
departments in the Sinovel protests a
reason a reason that a police car has a
push bumper is to clear a path because
they are not the only first responders
remember our heroes but I know it only
applies to furloughed nurses in South
Africa well yeah if we were actually in
a fascist nation seeing the CNN guy
couldn't stand in front of a bunch of
cops by the way you don't get to pick
and choose which laws you follow this is
a rule you have a curfew for a reason
oh other than just you know like
breaking the curfew I don't know why
they moved in and started arresting
people I don't know maybe ya never know
why let's hurry I want to listen to this
reporter by the way like I said already
but it's just interesting is that Tim
Poole calling I think he's come first
let me well hold on guys did guys let me
know what's going on let me know when we
have them and then we can bring him on
we were gonna do a commercial break
before we brought Tim Poole on
I'm sorry audio wait good on-air but
then I forget that sometimes you're also
good off heroin so he's not here able to
he's not able to help us there growing
good uh
go back to the not audio Tim hey look
two gays let's bring that volume up this
is two guys one perimeter line from
everywhere all right come on we'll check
back we got to check in who have a lot
of places in and in the states tonight
that we need to check on New York City
is one of them the other one is
Washington DC that's where we'll find
Alex Marquardt for us Alex watch watch
they're gonna [ __ ] about Donald Trump's
walls erected maybe if you didn't break
down barriers in trying form the White
House yeah they wouldn't need a wall
build a wall you try and say it's
symbolic we have to hold him for one
second get away with this guys in pool
and I also want to see if he has a
preference for sweat through downtown DC
adapter really in admiration of the
resilience of these protesters he could
be two places in it-- and the
Metropolitan Police Department said that
they were not going to enforce that
curfew as long as people stayed peaceful
Don I do want to point out this this
fence that you were mentioning they had
erected this oh that's right drink
everybody and the reason why we gently
mentioned a peaceful protest or imply
that Trump is a racist or America is
systemically racist or no arrests made
last night because they couldn't push
down the fence yeah yeah barricade they
were just shoving it through and of
course harming officers in the process
in the process well you know I remember
the rest turns out walls work yes they
do we should do some more CrossFit
making yeah scale those walls or push
them down
yeah but they blow out their shoulders
before they get get the dialysis machine
get the dialysis machine for your blood
kidneys it's for your kidneys
rhabdomyolysis is where you get creating
90 in the blood and so you can actually
I really shouldn't have yeah you should
have known he already has
[Laughter]
CrossFit don't start none won't be none
all right made that the mascot Uncle
rhabdo and it's a clown hooked up to a
dialysis machine really because they're
like I trained so hard that my deleted
breaks down and tissue gets into my
blood and toxify zit isn't that fun
no gross and now you're sick all right
we have Tim Poole mr. Poole are you
there sir
I am indeed can you hear me oh we just
saw someone who looked a little bit like
you there he had your beanie on can you
confirm in fact this is not green-screen
trickery you are not at the White House
I am not actually at the White House but
you know some people try to do what I do
and report right the greatest form of
flattery you know it is also if your
calling card is going to be an item that
can be procured for six dollars at
targets you know it's not necessarily
copyright materials unfortunately for me
cover though it can be looted so there
is that it's free um you just had a
stream going on right Tim Poole I did
yes and what were you guys talking about
the stream we've been watching CNN and
it's been remarkable that they have been
trying to avoid going to the ground
tonight yeah at all costs they're not
showing the ground the one time they cut
to the ground we heard what sounded like
mortars going off the police
respectfully asking folks to honor the
perimeter they said no and then we
hadn't gone back until just now so what
have you guys been covering Minneapolis
is talking about disbanding their Police
Department and what city funding of
police yet totally disbanding it Wow
yeah so that's where we're at and we
just had some conversations about what
would that would mean I mean it sounds
crazy but there's actually some
arguments for why it might work if you
consider what black lives matter
activists have been talking about this
guy Hank Newsom is having armed
community patrols so they're responsible
for their own community and their own
policing there's an argument for a
conversation to be had I'm not saying
it's perfect but I was thinking about it
I'm like all the two-way people would
probably have probably probably be happy
to see all of these liberals now
defending the right to bear arms yes
that's interesting responsibility for
their own safety and stop putting the
responsibility on police
and rescue them when you know crime is
happening right but they don't work but
they don't want to defend the Second
Amendment they really just wanted to go
to a federal level where they can indict
people who disagree with them that's the
problem they literally want gulags
the crazy ones well I don't know I mean
as Rasheeda Talib suggested that hey we
expand the Second Amendment cuz this is
you know right yeah the most vocal
legislator that I know in other words if
someone said hey defund the police and
let's have a robust defense of the
Second Amendment I would listen to them
I've only heard defund the police from
people who also say strip the Second
Amendment a mime am I mistaken because I
want to be corrected mostly corrects
mostly correct okay it's just
Hank Newsom he's a black lives matter
leader I think based out of New York who
said we need to arm ourselves and be
responsible for our communities and that
solves the problem it's an interesting
argument yeah Minneapolis isn't saying
that they're saying we're discussing
disbanding the police because
irredeemably broken and they don't know
what the alternative is right so maybe
start with with with a transition or an
alternative before you talk about just
getting rid of the police is right is
you know ultimately what we talked about
is maybe the city living has become
untenable it's just you've got too many
problems right you can't afford it
smells like sour milk maybe it's time to
move out of these cities that's very
generous when I walk through New York
City
I smell human [ __ ] you know just see
human [ __ ] you know I want this man
taking Tompkins Square Park not a joke
took a [ __ ] and then he reached into his
pocket I swear to you this is true no he
took reach into his pocket took out
there was a syringe in his finger and
rather than using his other hand to pull
it out he just went like this like it
was so casual reaches into practice and
dirty syringes so he took a [ __ ] pulled
up his pants Reese into his pocket and
there's a syringe like like it was a fly
that was in the san francisco tourist ad
right there's your Sanford wait his
Tompkins Square Park San Francisco no no
I'm cool excuse me what was that Tim
Poole that's New York isn't it yeah
that's what I was thinking but an audio
Wade stepped on me
geez I wasn't listening he makes a
horrible
something else too I want to know for
people who don't if you're very confused
cultural appropriation months you're
doing Norway today tympole we talked
about this earlier today you and I off
air so you obviously are more of a
moderate and you've never owned a
firearm before correct nope never now it
seems like your opinion has changed and
that you like and welcome Tim pulls
audience explained to me when your flash
of genius was when that moment was that
you wanted to get a firearm it wasn't it
wasn't a flash of genius it was a couple
years ago I was still very much like
iris I respect people's right to own
firearms but I think there's some
reasonable arguments for control
measures and then someone messaged me on
my youtube channel saying if we can have
reasonable controls in the Second
Amendment then I want controls on your
First Amendment and I immediately was
like that's actually a really great
argument I concede so while I think you
know there have been issues concede
probably ready at there like with his
beer and he had his fate but he's like
alright I'm going to work to improve
your right police perimeter yeah okay so
that's it logic it's it's me saying you
know honestly I haven't had real
sit-down conversations with people who
were talking about how this functions
and there was a gap in my sight but I
something by one when Kovac started
escalating actually no I'm sorry I'm
sorry I gotta walk this back it was when
the pedophile showed up to my house at
4:00 in the morning and tried breaking
in when the police instructed me to go
buy a gun right in a manner of speaking
they said if it were me I'd opened the
door with a shotgun so I tried going
through the house yeah yeah good cops
yeah it dude it's it's it's tough it's
tough in New Jersey to get a gun well
that's what we were talking about so let
me know because listen you're in New
Jersey and obviously you know Manhattan
itself was like a war zone for several
days and some of the protests have been
peaceful where it's only a couple
hundred people in you know in smaller
areas where they marched but obviously
New Jersey can turn on a dime
so you were telling me it's hard to buy
a gun that can you tell me exactly what
what it is first off there are no
firearms to find right now they're
picked clean
right but what the process would be like
therefore for example like for a handgun
so the first thing I did was I called
some administration I can't remember
they said go to the police department I
go to the police department they gave me
conflicting instructions told me to fill
out a form then go online the website
didn't exist Wow I'm not kidding it's
like the DMV with boat with exit wounds
yeah yep
so what they told me I would have to
fill out and like like write an essay
I'm not kidding
they said I have to write an essay
explaining why I need one but I'm not
kidding is it totally serious
only so at that point I was just like
this is not I got to move out of the
state or something because they've given
me no clear instructions they couldn't
tell me what I was supposed to do where
I was supposed to go so more recently
with kovat and everyone rushing to the
stores I started looking into it again
but didn't get serious until the
full-blown riots nationwide and that's
when I was like I'm gonna actually spend
the time and do the hard digging and I
found some path towards getting away
getting a gun in New Jersey right that
had me fill out a form with a bunch of
numbers I didn't know what they meant it
told me to find complete case compliant
numbers which weren't included in
anything no instructions at all right
and I really do believe they try to make
it as hard as possible for a regular
person who's never bought a gun before
to go through the hoops of actually
buying one right finally I got to the
point where I could fill out the federal
ID or whatever went and dealt with
fingerprinting and things like that and
it's any my dream this it was during
this in-between period that you were
raped
correct via a very large evil monster
came out of my closet yes named John
lemon so a couple first off a couple of
things because I understand I know that
you have you have some some compound
bows if I'm not mistaken right that's
kind of what you're using right now I
got a bunch at a time yeah for compound
bows for recurves to Hungarian
traditionals
is robbing and this is this is more
because it's fun
you know we went we weren't thinking
that we're gonna be like ninja warriors
with bows or whatever no no we're we're
actually like we want to go range
shooting and have a good time you know
just have fun
no I actually wanna we want to get guns
for security yeah no sticking a broad
head in a looter can be a good time fun
for the whole family
well let me explain some of you so we
talked about this earlier today I want
everyone to know full disclosure I
talked about it with with Tim and my
heart went out to him because I come
from a place in Canada where you can't
protect your stuff it's rely on the
government and then well we're gonna
disband the police force so first off a
big thanks to obviously our sponsor
Walther but they specialize in handguns
and I want to thank sig sauer who
they're actually sending us since we
can't find any here a whole lot of sig
365 V crammed there jacketed hollow
points we only have some range ammo and
even them writes out a nine-millimeter
and here's the things been out for a
while we obviously wanted to send our
sponsor Walther but I don't even know if
they have anything compliant with New
Jersey and handguns are a lot harder to
get in New Jersey long guns are a little
bit different so we will be sending you
now courtesy of sig I have to say this
legally but we will be the one sending
you actually a brand new Sig Sauer M 400
thread it's a sporting semi-auto rifle
in the ar-15 family or platform again
it's from me compliments of sig because
we told them about your scenario they're
actually going to we're going to send it
directly to your FFL and they will
immediately make the adjustments needed
to make it New Jersey compliant which
typically means shittier but you getting
it is better than than nothing and when
we're done with this hit up we'll
probably talk tomorrow and will expedite
that to you because I know how hard it
is
thanks man seriously yeah I white fire
yeah but you can use it I mean that's
that's cool
no actually I'm kind of mad cuz I want
one of these yeah yeah let me can I use
it are you allowed to come to New Jersey
I don't know if I'm allowed to come in
New Jersey I'm gonna get a serious ass
whoopin and here's one thing I want to
show you I don't know if I can tipsy
programmer just sees me he sees you he
sees me so right now again Don Lemon is
showing two black guys from the Floyd
family he showed attorneys from the
Floyd family but a friend from Floyd and
now there's
attorneys right here for the Floyd
family they are not going to the ground
which is remarkable to me I don't know
if you've been following this and
something else did you were you aware of
you know we just had reg the bandit
bring this up were you I'm sure you were
aware of Donald Trump posting that very
heartfelt tribute to George Floyd where
he called for unity where he said we
need more hugs and fewer clenched fists
and that was removed from Twitter for
copyright they still have information up
there by the way that's false about the
NYPD unloading on a 19 year old boy
unarmed it was actually a
thirtysomething year-old who was I
believe shooting at the cops
so no fat check on that but they removed
Donald Trump's video and then CNN Don
Lemon just said and Donald Trump
couldn't take a minute out of his day to
honor George Floyd yeah have you been
following it and are you aware of that
copyright video that was taken down from
Trump no I'm hearing about it just now I
knew I know he put it up but yeah the
things Twitter is doing you know if you
search racist on Twitter Donald Trump is
the first thing that pops up really Wow
yes Wow it's that dude the things I've
been seeing in the news and on social
media are getting freaky I don't think
it was bad last year like you would have
on the New York Times they're having an
internal revolt their staff won an
opinion piece from Tom cotton removed
because he was supporting Trump's call
for military action oh yeah New York
Times is bending over backwards for
these people right now to be clear to
people just calling it the New York
Times are bending over for people who
are not Don Lemon not well yeah it
wouldn't be bad but yeah that so you
weren't aware that was taken down and
let me ask this do you think as someone
who specializes in this you know you
look at that sort of trail I think I
told you someone attempted to docks us
posted the wrong address so I just but I
don't want anyone to be nobody yeah six
times it took over 30 hours for Twitter
to get to it but right away when I
tweeted out today if you kneel before a
mob you're a [ __ ] that was reviewed and
to Twitter Twitter's credit wasn't
removed but that was reviewed within
minutes boxing isn't quite on their
priority let me know Twitter sent a
message because of co vid were
backlogged so let me ask you you think
that there is like triangulation almost
like picture you know velociraptors in
Jurassic Park to in the cornfield open
do you think that there's a concerted
effort where they go okay we're not
going to fact check this verifiably
false information on the NYPD
we're going to remove Donald Trump's
video on a copyright bogus claim even
though other videos that have way more
egregious copyright violations are still
allowed and then the media works with
them and says oh now we can go out there
and say that Donald Trump hasn't
commented on it do you think it's just
all happenstance that they don't have
researchers or do they have a direct
line of communication because that those
three things change the if people watch
CNN would change the entire public
perception of reality well what we can't
say definitively Twitter has admitted
they're only basically fact-checking
Trump and some conservatives their
official response was we don't intend to
correct every bit of misinformation that
being so the response to this was that
you know Joe Biden Hillary Clinton
Schumer I've put out false information
that is gone completely ignored and then
when Trump gets flagged Twitter's
responses well we don't flag everything
so it's just a process by the way that
felonious Floyd you see his name they
say felonious Aloni is its fellow no say
I think Floyd but it's just it's just a
weird coincidence I knew someone who was
once named ghen oriya really well I
don't think that's true I think it is
that person so let me let me ask this
Tim what is it that you think is the
most dangerous I guess right now in this
coverage my biggest concern and I talked
about this early on is and now I have
the Nicolas Cage Tim are you excited
about your ar-15 my biggest concern is
and how old are you mr. Poole they're 34
okay so you're two olders you're two
years older than me but one year younger
than brian Stelter that's no way to year
older than brian Stelter brian Stelter
is our age Tim Poole oh he's gonna be
around a while and this is new and
improved brian Stelter with my worry is
having been raised in a post-racial
world Canada post-racial America that
when you have the media saying this is
because of race it's black black black
black black lives matter black people
are watching and they're going my cities
destroyed and by the way I want to be
very clear there are black officers and
there are white looter
but the media is saying black black
black black black my worry is that you
have an entire generation of people more
racist because they go why is my town
destroyed and they flip on the TV and go
black that being said that's my biggest
concern
what's your biggest concern with the
coverage of all this which is I think we
would all agree is worse than it's ever
been in our life shocking yeah no I
agree with you so one of the things
that's been mind-numbing for me and it's
become a meme where I mentioned that I'm
I come from a mixed-race family is that
I'm in the worst position between these
two groups because I either bend the
knee I have I have no privilege amongst
them because they say I'm white right if
I disagree then they everything I say is
wrong if I so my only choice is to agree
with them otherwise I'm the other but I
literally don't even have the privilege
of being white literally like to how
they describe it because my family does
it the way the way I'm trying to put it
is their ideology puts me in the most
awkward position where I have no racial
identity like they do right these weird
white liberals talk about their
experiences in the suburbs I'm from the
south side of Chicago but then because
the way they perceive me they I don't
get the benefits of their ideology just
the detriment right so I I'm basically
trying to agree with you say no you're
screwed I know that he's not because he
is half Korean oh let's play that let's
play that audio hos like you can pull a
little bit of this you can pull that and
be a roof top career as a clip with your
m400 shred courtesy of us us but thank
you sake for helping us apply it let me
let me let me reiterate this in a better
way I have been I have interviewed white
supremacists you know nationalists and
they have disdain for me and my family
and they say they say awful things yeah
I don't care though it rolls off my back
if the left wins your hairless Korean
back here in that Steve King look Steve
King gets loses his primary because he
said things that Americans didn't want
to hear right of things that were
considered either white nationalist or
racist the left is emboldened by their
racists and these weird things that
freak out me and my family so my hope is
that American as the identity survives
and that's what
because that's the only thing I have
where's there's no rush no outcome yeah
with these right with these weird
identitarian on the left or the right
where I win and my family wins right if
people in my position are gonna do
better it's gonna be Americans
recognizing they're just American first
and foremost but if we end up with white
identity anism I'm screwed and if we end
up with Lebanon to tarian ISM I'm
screwed so I'd rather just we all be
Americans and agree on our civil rights
I agree I think that's very well said
let me ask you this because I know that
you said in the past you know you were
moderate I think you voted for Obama
correct the first time the first time
and the second man did you not vote or
did you vote not about okay
Romney's pretty tough if your mom's
difficult the Mormon who puts his dog on
his roof and I think he's wrong
politically it's a tough sell but let me
ask you say it fair you've said before
like obviously you you you're not
necessarily a big fan of Donald Trump
but do you now take into account after
these riots that have vote for anyone
other than Donald Trump is a vote for
someone who wants you to have only a
double-barreled shotgun or revolver with
more extensive paperwork than you're
talking about now there's no two ways
about it yes yeah yeah so I do I did
this show the Tim cast IRL show with my
buddy Adam and Lydia Adam is a
skateboarding hippie liberal guy group
Chicago lives in New York
and he just comes out and he's like
after seeing all this I'm voting for
Trump and I was like whoa wow wow wow I
I was talking to someone recently
someone I've known for a really really
long time
diehard Democrat as long as I've known
them messaging me saying the only way
this ends is if Trump wins re-election
and the Republicans take all you know
the house in the Senate and I was like
whoa Wow for real and you know I was
talking to a local in my area contractor
and I was asking him how they felt about
all this they said to me they don't care
for politics it was this guy who's in
his mid-20s did a construction work and
he said you know honestly man I don't
know anything about this stuff but I'm
gonna vote for Trump because I'm sick
and tired of the attacks I just don't
understand why they're always yelling
and complaining so I'm just gonna vote
for this guy now well this was soul
mates tell me he didn't vote for Trump
the first time he is now I combine these
things with everything I see with what's
going out Biden
falling asleep and just being out of his
mind yeah the progressives ragging the
Democrats and I can't envision a future
where Trump loses so right and by the
way he said he did say diehard Democrats
was the worst a sequel of the diehards I
was playing taking a knee saying never
Paul let me ask you Tim not to put in
you don't if you believe in a secret
ballot has this changed do you think
that where you are now would you cast a
vote and has it changed
I'm not definitively confirmed for Trump
but I have stated leaning in that
direction all right and there's reasons
for this so Democrats are done for me I
I donated to them recently yang Tulsi
but with with what they've done with him
impeachment with what they did with
rigging the DNC with how they shut out
the candidates that I wanted to hear
from I just said you know what man these
moderate Democrats in Congress ran on
kitchen table issues and then as soon as
they were given the one ring they
laughed and went right for impeachment
yeah
and that's something that's not worth
supporting right cuz I still get text
messages from these people and I said
listen men I know that if I support you
you're telling me all your whispering
sweet nothings into my ear about the
policies you want to enact and then
you're gonna go and scream about Trump
for twenty years and I don't want to
hear it so it's not happening when it
comes to the president I'll tell you
what scared me is Joe Biden they've lost
their minds yes they have like their
minds and he kneeled he kneeled which to
me melt that is so well is it is Nelse
the world
I believe it's melt man these beers are
strong canal time well a couple of
things there you know Andrew yang I'm
sure you saw his tweets where he was
encouraging like insurrection has that
changed your opinion I know it does oh
yeah kind of a dick move
I have to tell you I know you're kind of
obviously I appreciate your journalistic
integrity but if you don't vote for
Trump you don't get your signature post
it on Twitter the picture of an illegal
picture of you in the voting booth
all right Tim well Tim what we do have
to get going where's the best place for
people to find you and watch your new
show youtube.com slash Tim cast IRL on
Twitter at Tim casts I mean honestly if
you search YouTube for Twitter I have
like three or four channels all under
the same thing oh you're still showing
up in search well that's cute
the six-hour m400 shred and like we said
we couldn't send you a handgun so uh at
this point Walter has been a wonderful
sponsor to the show yeah but it's more
important that people are able to
protect themselves if they don't sell
any rifles and I've had great experience
with with I've always said this it's
like BMW Mercedes at a certain point
yeah they're all very good once you get
beyond you know the Saturday night
specials are no tourists yeah so we
wouldn't do that because I don't I don't
want you to actually be raped that
wouldn't send you a tourist yeah that's
the m400 you need a you know you'll be
in touch with us and there do need to be
some modifications there in New Jersey
for us to send it out but thank you so
much brother
stay safe I appreciate it thanks for
making the time likewise take care man
all right take care
someone take the microphone I wanted to
bring up I don't know al Sharpton when
he was at the George Floyd Memorial said
one of the lines that just kind of
scroll to cross there on the lower third
said we couldn't be who we wanted to be
because you wouldn't take your knee off
our neck or you had your knee our neck
this is a problem I think every single
time people see the only reason you're a
failure the only reason you're having
trouble that you're not where you want
to be in life is because you're black
and everything is being blamed on the
system being racist against you instead
of the fact that maybe you didn't study
very hard that you didn't apply yourself
that you didn't work hard at what you
wanted to be
instead of taking personal
responsibility it boils it down to one
issue there are so many things that
determine because I see black people
that are very successful yeah Stacey
Abrams right there Don Lemon there's
another one there's two on the screen
right now
she's petted successful right funny
again she said she wouldn't down from
being governor to run as vice president
he's not actually govern I don't put
sorry and it was a battle on B that was
a battle on B headline I gotta give
credit where credit is due I loved
hopefully she'll be or Clift's down well
yeah well it said use your yeah it takes
a minute well and that kind of mentality
for me is what drives this yeah exactly
everything is because you're black
that's the only reason and so what do
you do you feel hopeless yeah I can't
change black why try because I'm not
gonna be able to fast there's there's no
personal responsibility there's no me
trying to make it out right nothing like
that it's all because you're black you
can't change that so you might as well
overthrow the system and we'll just see
what comes from the ashes we have no
plan
just anarchy let's try that right that's
what they want well yeah can you hold
that thought brooms has to say
big pronounces and they're going to be
inadequate but their progress and
progress matters progress is how we get
to the change we all depends what you're
progressing towards hey Linda funding
police and anarchy the shitty evil carte
blanche to continue and we like the
writers look it down look at the Don
Lemon little smirk thank you so much I'm
so glad you said that
that was my boyfriend didn't have to it
looks a little like a ghost alive still
there's this like an astral projection I
don't know I just he looks like an old
lady across the country there's also
outrage tonight in Sacramento after a
22-year old was shot by police in a
nearby city an investigation is underway
and with police under the microscope
right now there are more we're gonna
take a look at those investigations next
how about the rioters and looters being
under a microscope yes well that's one
thing that bonds would say they say the
protests which are largely peaceful you
saw the highlight reel they're not
largely peaceful if I have a party
tonight okay yeah and I understand that
some are peaceful for a period if I
invite us all to everyone here to a
dinner party and the first hour is a
lovely dinner party yes I'm at gabs nice
in the last five hours are an orgy well
is it still a party or is it an orgy
yeah I'm glad how was the tri-tip good
why don't you drop your keys in the jar
over there and
I'll go home with your wife the point is
it is no longer a party if you meet and
you plan on being peaceful or at least
just allow yourselves to be peaceful
yeah for the amount of time that the Sun
is up and the cameras are running and
then twelve deaths over three hundred
and seventy officers killed harmed sorry
over 25 million dollars in property
damage to Minneapolis these are just
estimates by the way many many many
thousands of arrests at arrests at what
point do you say well maybe it's just an
orgy yeah what were you about to say
their audio wait yeah I was just saying
that you know we were talking with the
al Sharpton query said something about
like we had our you had your knee on her
neck or something we couldn't be we
didn't - yeah we defined his neck with a
map or compass now it's very looks
that's true yeah yeah but but evidently
that isn't applied to all the success
that black people have had in music yeah
or all the success of black we never had
in sports in the majority Dario
how dare you the majority of the NFL the
majority of the I do believe we had a
black president as oh yeah I don't
remember sure yeah and just to echo the
point Gerald mate if if your are preach
to your entire life that everything that
you do there's always going to be some
kind of ceiling that you cannot get past
because you're black right then of
course you're gonna feel hopeless that's
a recipe for depression it's a recipe
for yeah again another group you know a
group that is has faced racism their
entire existence in two states the
Asians
oh yeah right Asian people have been
have been hammered the entire time with
racism and yet they teach gonna say they
were hammered and Asian yeah well he
doesn't hold them very well but you know
what they build their kids go out and
work hard right right it's just a
different mentality that's mostly well
said that if you believe you live in a
system that is against you fight the
system by doing better than that system
yeah recede inside that system so you
can say right I won despite all these
giveaway be beard you know for
runner what are my grades because if the
system was actually again somebody that
would be a problem and yes it would be
yammering upon white peope digication
system which we've done before by the on
exam yeah right now of systemic
discrimination systemic racism in this
country one police brutality ten unarmed
black men most of whom deserved it shot
last year nineteen white guys again most
of whom deserved it I'm an equal
opportunity offender yeah yeah most of
the white guys were being unruly
attacked the cops most black guys did as
well on any given year there are more
white guys one armed white guy shot by
police officers and black people and
that's not genocide so that doesn't work
name me any systemic discrimination is
it the halls of government well no we
had a black president we have plenty of
black senators we have plenty of black
congressman is it the halls of education
no black people right now can get lower
test scores lower SAT results than white
people or Asians Asians at Brown are
pretty pissed off yeah in hiring no
that's not the case what is it is it in
public schools no there's more per pupil
funding in these public schools
unfortunately it's funneled through a
corrupt School Boards like in Detroit
where doesn't actually get to the
students name me one area where there is
systemic discrimination against black
people and then Nate if you could even
find one which you can't so I'm being
redundant here then show me it it's
because of white people yeah I can tell
you one area where black people really
are suffering and I would like to see it
fix and that's why I think the crimes of
George Floyd matter is dying in record
numbers at the hands of black people
yeah I really I think that and I really
encourage black citizens to exercise our
Second Amendment rights so for example
that woman who George Floyd jammed a
pistol into her pregnant belly I really
would prefer if that headline red man
chased off front porch by armed black
woman people say you're afraid you're
afraid of strong black men or strong
black women really then why would I why
am i encouraging you to purchase
firearms no I'm not afraid we are I'm
strong but I want strong black man I
want strong black women because weak men
black white red yellow join mobs weak
men join misinformation campaigns strong
men white or black defend the pregnant
woman we had five guys if I'm not
mistaken five guys in George Floyd's
Posse who J
who rammed their way through this
woman's door and by the way I'm talking
we just went through a miscarriage in my
family and that is somewhat devastating
okay yeah
you don't think that you're more likely
to have that happen when you have in a
45 Jam into your stomach doesn't mean
you deserve to be killed by the officers
not at all but the problem in the black
community right now the problem that is
far more pervasive is that it is a much
more common occurrence for a George
Floyd type to rob a fellow black
American in their neighborhood than it
is for a police officer to shoot an
unarmed black man and it's not even
close
statistically you can't make an argument
period and one point I would like to
make quarterblack Garrett you're a
perfect example we thought you were
Mexican that's true so just like like
temple said like I don't have either one
right right I can't do good in either
way like if I live in that said well if
you believe that the difference is far
as I'm concerned you can do good on both
sides right fence right but when you
were in Bolivia and then you told me
like no I'm black I'm bi I said your
corner black that was the nickname but
in other words you weren't brought in
imagine if we only if we hired you you
said you recorder black and then we
hired you that day and then immediately
we call you quarter black you'd probably
feel like a topi like right why that's
weird but the fact that we otherwise it
was funny that yeah no one ever knows
you're black we're not it's very clear
that we weren't using you for the first
like I do you can translate that you put
it on you put it on because you talk
about tacos and [ __ ] I love tacos
Lopez tonight she's trying to take
advantage Mexican privilege man I'm
trying to write another night yeah well
and and again if the black lives matter
movement really cares about black lives
just getting back to the point you're
making what about what about the hundred
thousand babies that were aboard last
year the right back there were 100 that
like so again yeah ten black people were
killed last year by police officers you
know a hundred thousand black babies are
reported if you care about
proportionally responding and that's the
thing you should be focusing on but
don't care everything but I hate because
someone will take it out of context in
fact check you not ten people total
killed by black black [ __ ] officers
ten unarmed men were shot by officers
okay
think people looking for a race war like
CNN right they'll try and catch you on
that even though the spirit of what you
just said was very important yeah
exactly this I hope you know I'm not in
monitor no no please I just don't want
you to get in trouble he thinks only ten
people because I know what we're doing
for our broadcast and I was imprecise my
apologies no you don't be imprecise I'm
saying this is what my life has been for
you get one of those things wrong it
doesn't matter that Don Lemon said
Donald Trump hasn't taken I'm out of his
day to discuss George Floyd even though
he uploaded what a four-minute video
yeah and at least several dozen
statements they don't care but someone
like you or me
might be fact checked if we say only ten
black men were shot by officers [ __ ]
what are you talking about we meant to
say and you could see at least forty
times throughout the show we said only
ten unarmed black men were shot by
Officer exactly I don't bring it up to
at all at mantra bring it up to so that
people can see the real live double
standards so please here's what I do
encourage people out there and we know
Young Turks we know that you're watching
you are looking for tip because we know
that you know no context I beg you Adair
take it out account context please
Candice Owens us they never do they
never know they never do fifty thousand
people watching right now they will not
Wow nope we don't have that extended
clip by the way oh yeah let me be really
clear about this right so right we have
the original clip by itself or no no I
just had the extended so the original
commencing you back the show that she
coming out this Korean who was a and
everyone thought it was really funny
because you know yeah never really
command of the was passionate but he
doesn't have great commanding language
yeah
but like we were just talking about with
you in the statistic it doesn't mean
that the spirit was wrong right in his
heart Wade also doesn't have great you
know facts people know that he's the
star of the show
he doesn't have least on fire is
language and I just want to make sure
that we're transparent about it because
we have exclusive footage that was
extended showing that he doesn't fully
have command of the language but I still
think the spirit is is the same it's
about someone else's mom writers were
high yeah he turned that that dragon
gone I'd way yes right that's a gangster
move right yeah there was a whole arc of
the insults yeah yeah yeah the same
understand with the man blessed with the
looting and more so with him being an
unselfish lover history which children
he loves his mom touching it's kind he's
a guy look you know is the unselfish
[Music]
Daniels the guy from sandals confuse
with Amadeus different one of them
includes Rock Me Amadeus you say this
the single greatest thing that you can
do to help the black community community
that struggling right now is to tell
them that they have personal
responsibility to tell them that they
can affect change for themselves and for
their families not to tell them that
everything is out of their control and
I'm sorry it's because you're black or
it's because you're whatever white Asian
whatever you can't achieve something
because of who you are everybody can
achieve we've seen it throughout the
entire country tell them that yeah tell
them the truth
don't sugarcoat it just be honest and
doing in a loving way is fine saying
look I know it's tough here's the thing
you can have a tough life and be a
victim your entire life or you can
realize it's tough pull yourself back up
and you can try your hardest you're
gonna just see the articles of people
saying white guys say this limit I grew
up in MIT lower middle class I moved 13
times before I graduated from high
school I could have gone oh crap life is
just gonna brighten up we're gonna be
poor the rest of our lives or I could
say I'm gonna give it my all I'm gonna
try my hardest yeah I'm gonna study hard
I'm gonna practice hard I'm gonna try to
do everything I can with this six foot
four frame yeah and make it or I can
just sit there and say well that's just
my dad lived in the hood he was poor his
whole life and pulled himself out of
there and then made himself better he
went to college he got a degree you know
you can do it when I live in the hood
you can do it
when I met Gerald he was missing half
his teeth all right you bring up seeing
it the only reason I have a lot to say
about this yeah and then I want to go to
bed you bruised it read show us what's
going on in the ground let's see done
lemon I recognize that I am part of the
solution and can be a leader for the
black community and this other problem I
am sick about the way my comments were
perceived yesterday but I take full
responsibility and reading apologize I
recognize that I should do less talking
and more listening and when the black
community is talking about their pain we
all need to listen for that I am very
sorry and I ask your forgiveness all
right so what he says does he not you
know what drew brees said he's reading
he's reading from Drew Brees he's not
the quarterback for the New Orleans
Saints he's reading he probably works he
probably know he probably works in the
community more than anybody in the NFL
right he spends a lot of his time and a
lot of his money helping people out he
said I would never disrespect the flag
by I think he even said by - respect the
flag in general egos but here's the
thing the full quote when I think of the
flag I think of the men and women who
served this country in world war two and
war one I think of the men and women who
fought for equal rights during the 60s I
think and he said all of these things
and he said and I would never do
anything to disrespect that and
everybody blew up at him and said how
dare you say that because they tell you
one part he was no in that one part
he was 100% right only correct if we go
out there listen so Taylor Swift I think
she put on corn rows in a watermelon in
a music video and they said whoa whoa
whoa whoa that's that's offensive to us
and she said okay hey I'm sorry these
guys knelt returing than that it was
these guys knelt during the national
anthem and we said whoa whoa whoa that's
offensive to millions of Americans don't
do that do it on your own time do it on
your own time as people are paying to
watch for exactly right right now you
tuned in to watch the scene in fact
check and instead I had the guy from how
did they get on the album they didn't
have the warnings that came with tipper
gore yeah Bill Cosby saw and said
warning rated E for Everyone I think it
is you're hungry yeah because there's
nothing better than a room-temperature
poultry three hours into it is very cool
hey don't judge you know to reg the by
the way the probe the hashtag is Crowder
riot stream the promo code is Viking
because it's cultural appropriation
right you will get $20 off if you join
my club we're not doing this to just
promote my club but keep in mind none of
this is paid we have 15 people here who
are paid we have a lot of security
probably gonna get some hounds to patrol
this area when we're no longer here that
is useless but uh very so if you want us
to continue doing the work that
journalists refused to do we would
appreciate
if you join my club reg the bandit if
you are there make sure you unmute your
microphone hopefully you're not falling
asleep because of Don Lemon anything
that we're missing because right now we
have seen nothing nothing from the
ground at all on CNN so I don't have
anything on ground
I actually actually have a clip that we
can go to in a minute but I thought it
might be interesting to follow up on Tim
fools note about the Minneapolis Police
Department being abandoned I've got an
overlay if you pull up the councilmember
who's doing this Oh see if he looks a
little familiar oh that's that what no
that's guy was that the guy who said you
can leave or stay and the truth is they
cannot stay because it's law oh I think
oh he's muted yourself again this is
keith ellison son and the Minnesota
Attorney General who famously posted a
picture of itself with an aunt of a
handbook rose oh now that's a giver just
connect the dots a little bit here we'll
see that in the last week jeremiah
ellison also declared that he officially
supported anta [ __ ] he did genius movie
bar do we know do we know there's a
little bit of a pattern there yeah do we
know if he really supports antemer no
let me read this he says it i hereby
declare officially my support for anta
unless someone can prove to me an tyfa
is behind the burning of black and
immigrant owned businesses in my word
only those people are terrorists that
are actually attacking us well hon a
second is there any proof that white
power terrorists are actually attacking
right because there are about as many
white power activists in the country as
there are members of the Westboro
Baptist Church and the same amount of
them have flippers yes very easy to
centrifuge it isn't it funny when they
say an to foes an idea it's not an
official organization but then he
pledges his support or that organization
I pledge they burn
what if they burn like a white business
he said if they burn a person of colors
business you know and my commune well
white it's really I don't think all
point starts off in white except for the
toxic fumes that are added that's what
creates the color yeah well that's
helpful to know it is helpful to know
because I was going to whitewash that
vandals
mural over there in Dallas but everyone
here what are everyone here post out not
everyone is not given in temperature
you're always against your street your
that corner street you're all three you
would have lost red you're a more street
than I think your firepower can allow so
I have to be careful yeah you got a hold
me back yes still in the trunk can we
address this whole concept that maybe
disbanding the police is not a terrible
get some amulets on him and he's mister
tough I'll get my hair over my face it
was more uncomfortable in the riots reg
the Bandit what do you said you had a
clip you wanted to go to first off so it
seems like it is definitively and it's
not the night is young more peaceful
tonight then let's say two nights ago
which tells me that upping the police
and sending in the military may work a
little bit yeah so I do think that that
is the takeaway you know Trump push to
have the National Guard and you know
military forces help out the police
departments and I think what we're
seeing is that happen and so I think oh
no he burned he always ashes himself
carry on okay okay
no Stephens not burning them appear you
soon right now go ahead reg I think this
video might have been having a little
bit of trouble with this clip but I was
just looking at this clip that I thought
to be fair we have some footage of some
police officers having a little bit of
an altercation for the old man and so
you might get fed to that I'm not sure
I'd like to get you guys yeah yeah
Reggie says it's not available for us oh
it's no longer available is that like
down B right yes can you describe the
clip show us their regice yeah I'm
watching it live on a few Twitter
accounts it could be because it's set as
potentially sensitive content but
essentially you have a line of these
trying to block off an area and an older
man comes up sort of pushes back against
a little bit and they push back it's him
he stumbles backwards in his head and
started we go there we go we got the
clip playing right now okay oh my gosh
so they show the off they show the old
man back oh gosh
yeah yeah help him and that guy was he
got on his radio he was absolutely it
was absolutely I think those police
officers should be held accountable yeah
didn't have to do that yes I think that
just goes to show you you know there are
two sides I don't we are not I don't
think it's conservatives winning some
police state no of course not right but
I do think there's work to call law
enforcement when you doing a Brian
separate work so you know just to show
both sides or it that's no you're
absolutely right and it's also why like
I said people out there don't be a hero
and go down to these protests because
you saw that guy on I'm trying to member
now was a Tuesday morning we went down
to Dallas so many yes it was it was
Tuesday morning Wednesday morning was
the morning I wanted to go back with the
paint roller and you good morning and we
interviewed that guy black gentleman who
token Owen had to describe the police
and he went to great lengths to try to
avoid saying he said y'all why people in
the penthouses we spare in you Yeah
right as though every time burns in our
lives
any insulted me saying clean haircut
Clint Clark can't look and was like oh
no I have super power that's like when
your parents can spank you but they send
you to your room you're like that's the
your you know what Dad the worst part of
all this is your disappointment Sega
Genesis so we went what was the point of
what was it reg 700 so in other words
picture that person who was saying we're
sparing y'all and I
what would justice be remember yeah you
can go back and watch that segment he
didn't have an answer
I said no well what would justice be I
said would third degree murder now it's
second degree murder he said no that's
not enough there was no logic at all
picture that person times ten thousand
times twenty thousand yeah there's no
reasoning with them and so there's no
sense in going down to these protests to
try and even to try and deescalate if
you're not a police officer because you
can get caught in the crossfire and keep
in mind that police officer may not be a
bad guy maybe a good cop but right now
you're in a you're in a pressure cooker
where everyone is on edge and they are
trying to establish a perimeter so that
you don't firebomb the white house or a
building whatever it is and they might
any shove you and that's and that's
wrong they should that police officer
shouldn't have done it but the point is
this really I mean I just go back to
that Thursday last week one week ago do
you guys remember whether there's a
guest yeah the up angles not flattering
bro not for you like Gretchen from reset
keep hearing the point that I'm making
yours Thursday I remember saying just
please stop no matter which side you
yeah you line up this is more people are
going to die
this is not going to help please stop
please stop please stop
and then we had the David Doran
situation that we talked about on that
on Wednesday and I was trite you know I
try not to be one of those broadcasters
like at Don Lemon it just goes out there
and cries but I think you got and I
appreciate you guys helping me it was
really hard for me to take tough to
watch that afterward I went I'm not
gonna I went home and I was upsetting my
wife was ask me III I cried I did I
cried in my wife's arms which is why
wives are wonderful because you can be
vulnerable and I just said listen you
know what's so sad is that was life
isn't a movie and that was a good man
who lost his life to evil yeah the bad
guy won that day the bandit the guy with
the bad guy the villain shot a good guy
and ran off with the TV and as far as I
know there hasn't been any justice and
even worse that guy doesn't get a mural
David Dorn yeah that guy doesn't get a
March even though not only is he black
not only was his killing far more
senseless and conscious from the person
who did the killing
wasn't an accident that person killed
him to get a TV but it is also David
Dorn is far more indicative of the
problem plaguing the black community
right now that we would like to address
black people if you want to save black
lives you should use an example first
off David Dorn as far as I know didn't
rob a pregnant woman and stick a 91911
into her gut as far as I know it was a
police officer he was 70 something years
old at this point he was helping to
protect another business I believe was a
black owned business this was a good man
who was trying to help the community and
he was gunned down by a senseless piece
of garbage thug and that happens a whole
lot more than 10 times a year yeah and
it broke my heart because this was a man
who didn't have to die it wasn't an
accident it was over a TV and it happens
every single day we've been watching now
for over three hours and he mentioned no
any mention at all of David rules the
other guy's name reg the Bandit Patrick
the other the other police officer who
was black Patrick Patrick Underwood and
was in federal officer in Oakland
California who was open fire upon was
killed by the anti cop right yeah no
mention of any of them that's far
tonight so how long well yeah so yeah so
we talked about how Thompson's in the
National Guard and the everything seems
to at least subside somewhat or they sit
along peaceful right cNN has already
gotten ahead of that point by saying
that well Trump sending in the National
Guard even though things are relatively
peaceful right so one thing follows the
other
I don't like CNN is not allowed to even
interpret things in that way that
there's a cause-and-effect relationship
there right well it used to be and I
want to go to a break here because I do
have to pee but I'm gonna talk for one
second one second nope I thought you'd
literally meant one second Mississippi
well no I'm glad you brought that up reg
because there are there are moments in
time like police officers if you're out
there if you're watching this and you're
a cop just be careful right the the
micro the lens is focused on you right
now in every single action that you take
is under the microscope so be very
careful pushing an elderly man like that
you didn't have to do that now the guy
has some responsibility for
there and pushing back on the police
officers he didn't deserve to be pushed
down like he just seemed like he
couldn't catch his balance he was very
old that's also the danger it's horrible
fight people don't understand this yeah
you're the most troubling battle you can
hit your head in the concrete as we saw
yeah there's no do not get into a street
first of all as someone who has trained
in in combat not doing the Sean Hannity
my kung-fu and a screamer and Filipino
striking arts like you know we've all
done this here we have a gent through
club in the office and we do some boxing
I'm going to use my gun because if I'm
in a street altercation I either avoid
it at all costs I'm not going to fight
over ego or I'm trending my life and at
that point it's not going to be fists
it's going to be a firearm and
rightfully so and why did Paul Begala
[ __ ] Dame Edna so that this guy oh I'm
out I'm sorry I'm very angry about this
whole thing I can't believe there's
nothing with David Dorn it's just it it
really does tear me up inside that no
one is talking about it we used to say
you know the victors write history well
that's not the case anymore anymore cuz
these people will loose CNN is losing
and two foes losing their black lives
matter is losing but right now they are
attempting to write history
yeah and they and they're doing it
through lies we saw a proactive live
from Don Lemon not omission which I've
complained about which i think is really
bad happens all the time
but Don Lemon went up on television
tonight and said Donald Trump couldn't
take time out of his day to address it
that's a lie yeah that is a lie
now even or to leave that he doesn't
have the ability to do research in which
case CNN is useless or he proactively
lied and knows that Donald Trump
released a video that was then
subsequently taken down by Twitter in
which case CNN is useless do you
understand this this is to choose your
own path book and it all comes to Don
Lemon should be out of a job
CNN should know yeah right news
organization there's wondering right
primary so one one thing about the dorm
video that I really did appreciate and
we didn't get to talk about a whole lot
was the guy that was there that was that
bet it was actually moving like I know
what he was doing was he was like come
on oh gee come on oh gee like Ben he was
with him he said it was okay he's he
spoke over life after he died and he
said this is [ __ ] for all for a TV
we're better than a tease
at people this could cost him his life
the people that did this could have been
around right and other people could have
been around that would have been very
angry by him saying this and I really
appreciate it I don't think he's getting
enough credit for what he did but I
really appreciate what he was there and
that he didn't die alone he didn't die
just by himself he died with somebody
there at least doing something trying to
push back against darkness to some
degree I want to see how long let's
listen I want to see if shaved mustache
Hayek has was that he said the federal
government is not going to oversee it is
Gretchen from recess can someone bring
up a picture of Gretchen from SS
division the Justice Department can look
at police departments to determine
whether there is a pattern or practice
of discrimination and the Obama
administration was particularly I'm
going to only bring on male guests who
are gay and doesn't mean that you can't
be a good reporter but I feel like I
feel like he's crossing out people who
could maybe inform him that Donald Trump
did release a video because they're
eliminated unless they they love the D
well there he just opens his contacts
list your profile can you imagine the
government using his rolodex for contact
this is even a name it's just first name
sex last name swing oh middle nickname
Vietnamese line favorite position he
listed all oh wow all right here's one
thing we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break again the hashtag is
Crowder riot stream we will have more
from on the ground because CNN is not
showing it to you and when we come back
from this break we have a two-minute
break three minute break we got three
minutes okay we have a three minute
break from our wonderful sponsors of
course black rifle coffee and some new
sketches that you may not have seen we
come back we actually have this week
seven plus one seven plus one most often
heard excuses for looting we'll be right
back after this very short break and
hopefully my bladder doesn't explode
make sure the bathrooms free
of duty so health care and overtime at
two and a half three and a half and
dental we can do that
if you're listening on audio
you're probably wondering what's
happening right now if you're not
listening on audio subscribe at Apple
podcast Google Play and Spotify hey guys
listen lower 22 here you may know a
recent story from the folks at plummet
exposing Governor Andrew Cuomo's very
clearly defined nipple piercings pretty
open-and-shut case right not so fast
the real meat of this story began with
neocon shell and confirmed Twitter and
beta male steven crowder had this to
stay right there that may not be nipple
rings holdout nipple hair yeah and it
has those little like goose bumps come
on shouter it's so obvious that only a
solid material could make that kind of
impression through cloth so why would he
pretend otherwise unless he has
something to hide
unless Browder not only has twig arms
but he also has a Prince Albert hey
that's this for my wife me this this my
wife thanks for watching guys huge
announcement really quick
I've just been signed with an MCN
recently so prepare yourselves for truth
whisp Laura
[Music]
louder with crabber ranger pin why yours
today at louder with powder shop calm
hitler terrible Holocaust of course six
eight million Jews the number that you
guys give absolutely believe it I think
it was great injustice and of course I'm
fed the United States went in was the
the axis of evil all of those things
Hitler bad zero support but can Steven
really be trusted just say no to steven
crowder and mug club paid for by moms
can smoke club calm alright we are back
guys thank you very much for hanging out
with us it's ten seventeen and we have
no real news to ripped out no one not no
one bit of on-the-ground reporting that
we can actually come to you and say hey
CNN's doing their job got the long shot
going on no no no God is not right here
hold it is everywhere though it steven
is is telling me at the break he is
feeling compelled to kneel
but you shouldn't you sound old we may
the Twitter the Twitter Twitter's that's
by design just Twitter well I feel as
old as Don Lemon look that's frickin old
which I know I look older than my age
the irony's not lost on me
but um you shouldn't hate me as much
should say where are my papers your
papers are don't you through way way
last little segment
yeah no no no watch so see the last one
they're like you know what we got to
look like a fool so we might not not to
do it just me or just a really tone-deaf
commercial really and please PLEASE safe
right now yeah not a good the best time
Oh where's my mask my word they didn't
quite update it for the new corona but
let's watch Don Lemon for a little bit
see if there's anything of value and
then reg give us something saw on the
ground or something that we're missing
in the news here so that we can leave on
a semi high note friends community
leaders and celebrities as well the
family saying that they are moved by the
showing of support it's crazy all these
people came to see my brother
and that's ellonija Smith that he
touched so many people hearts you know
could he be in touch and I was feeling
me everybody fights with guns with all
the signers lately yeah have you noticed
the different um ik of signers
apparently they don't exist anymore I am
joined now by George Floyd's friend and
his former NBA player as well former NBA
player Stephen Jackson Stephen thank you
I appreciate and joining George Floyd
that connection co-star in big women you
could have had a good life without you
know being a by robbing person cool
crime you call George Floyd your twin
you were at that memorial service today
wouldn't you know his brother said he
was just so he couldn't believe so many
people came out you know for his brother
what was it like to see such beautiful
tributes to your friend protect and
provide for everybody really okay listen
and people get mad at me do you not
think it's important what everyone goes
he was nothing beloved man he was a
protector and provider he robbed a
pregnant woman and did five years and
had multiple multiple offenses this was
a violent man who hopefully every as a
Christian this is we believe every man
black or white can be redeemed now I
tend to lean toward if you have a
history of violent criminal
and then the autopsy reveals multiple
drugs in your system not saying you're a
bad person but you're probably still
struggling yeah you're probably still
struggling you probably have not you
have yet to be perfected and that's why
I believe that all of us we can only be
clean through the blood of Christ that's
what I believe is a Christian yeah and
you can't hear that on CNN no which you
know is probably it's probably the whole
funeral probably littered with it
because the black community is by and
large Christian but actually we suppress
right now that's a message that could be
unifying but we can't have that but when
everyone goes on and says man it was
nothing but love let me ask you this do
you think they'll say that about Donald
sterling right his crime was saying you
can have sex with black guys just don't
put it on social media and that's enough
that he will never be honored when he
dies regardless of impact and I'm not
saying that that wasn't wrong but I am
saying it's not as wrong as robbing a
pregnant woman violently at gunpoint
right and we have to act like this was a
saint listen exactly you think black
lives matter Mike Brown violent criminal
truth Trayvon Martin committing violent
assault George Zimmerman is an [ __ ]
everyone knows that but yours you are
today was a bigger [ __ ] you won the
[ __ ] contest that Mike Brown that
Officer Darren Wilson borderlines Saint
that guy didn't have anything wrong at
all he's trying to serve hands up don't
shoot was a lie and then in this case
you had a lot of sympathy from people
you still do in the sense that no one
thinks that this man should have died in
the custody of these officers but you're
actually going to lose that because
people feel like you're laying it on so
thick that they're gonna say yeah well
hold on a second he did strong armed
robber pregnant woman yeah can't be a
sec um on let's say what's gonna happen
is that's what you stick that's what
this are going to say about him who who
care about the truth they're going to
focus more on that because people tend
to focus on correcting a lying narrative
more than what we all might agree upon
because you're pushing a lie so hard it
very easily could have been a very
unifying moment right right yeah so
everybody sees the video everybody
unites around this was a horrible act
and shouldn't have happened let's all
unite around against against police
brutality
right and we can watch this video in all
condemn it but again yeah if you if you
paint a bunch of murals of this guy and
act as if he's some kind of exemple are
of your community then yeah we're gonna
that it's it's a little at least fair to
point out that he was insane well they
also took like t-minus one second before
they started looting stuff so yeah this
was nothing but peaceful protests there
have been peaceful protests that end up
turning into violent protests night one
right Minneapolis was on fire yeah night
one yeah yeah right night two on fire
again they were burning stuff that they
had burned the night more City certainly
had not burned enough can you imagine if
the Tea Party because of course they
were escorting oh my god you imagine if
the tea party rather than leaving places
cleaner than they found them ah set the
city ablaze right yeah what the only
think they would have been talking about
is you have to denounce these rioters
and these looters and these thugs they
would have been saying the exact same
thing right so everybody was already on
your side now you pushed everybody away
I saw one big story today was it was
Oakland and I think police released tear
gas there but but it was like but the
mainstream media is only pretty only you
know airing that clip yes and not the
clips of the courthouse fire and not the
clips of target being looted and CVS
being torn down yeah but the issue is
that both things happened Randy honest
yeah and you shouldn't play both videos
it's not don't just check which one okay
their narrative just cuz your job
donation it's because that's what you
tell us you do every single day
refreshed us we write all of the story
every bit of the information that you
need to make a decision and you're not
let me give you a very personal example
of this but as to this first off this is
clearly an entertainment show notice but
then for some reason it becomes news
when I go down a Muslim bakeries and ask
them to bake a [ __ ] cake yeah well
presented as news and when I did that
piece I went out of my way to say now to
be fair there were some bakeries who
were willing to bake a gay wedding cake
right but the majority weren't and the
point is the media has absolutely
destroyed the reputation of just one
bakery who by the way didn't refuse to
serve gay people
but refused to take part in a gay
wedding cake I went out of my way to say
some bakeries would some were very
friendly but the majority didn't and
that's what you see here and what comes
out in the news or else was selectively
edited I said that even anti-fur when we
infiltrated antiphon and they handed us
knives and ice picks right
we took the footage to the police
officers what happened the officers were
then watching this person one of them
handed my produce at the time Nakia had
a Taser so the officers no media by the
way had any interest in this footage no
and then the officer thank you for
attending whether infiltrating getting
on there and I understand that James
O'Keefe has sort of done a repeat of
what we've done as well yeah I think we
did about three years ago but I'm glad
you know they have more work
infiltration capabilities and we do
again because we're a comedy show that
was that was literally a portion of a
show with four shows that week right
yeah so I assume James O'Keefe will
obviously do a better job and thank God
that he is but we released the info we
said so listen this is the footage that
we had of them handing out weapons
planning on dating people to the cars
and shooting them with sawed-off
shotguns that footage itself didn't
result in the arrest of this girl but
the girl used the same taser that was
used on camera later on and they were
already watching her because of a video
that led to her arrest yeah the media
said no arrests
steven crowder lied about well we go out
of our way to be clear about it and in
this case they are proactively dishonest
they cover it up and they're never
called on it that's my issue with them
it's the dishonesty and a complete lack
of accountability and that's why you see
Twitter fact-checking Trump removing his
statements and videos calling for unity
that's why you see YouTube and Facebook
although Mark Zuckerberg now his own
employees are mad because he's not
politicizing everything as much that's
why you see them wanting to make room
for the big boys because they have a
stranglehold on information they don't
anymore
and so now they want to have a
stranglehold on the new media that was
an alternative used to be called
alternative media remember that yeah it
was called alternative media then it was
called new media and then the old-school
media realized well this is just media
and they said we're gonna use our dial
all of our dollars and we're gonna exert
pressure YouTube Facebook Twitter you
better play ball with us and then all of
a sudden people who are Ganic
built the platforms himself can no
longer be heard because Ted Turner and
Moonves have an opinion
we're gonna go to reg the band it really
then we're gonna go to our wrap up of
course exclusively at the blaze if
you're a mug Club member go to what does
it blaze blaze TV slash steven crowder
is a blaze tv.com slash live and try to
think when we bring it up there is home
slash live home slash live we'll find
the force you can watch on the app and
you can join it laterthe credit calm
slash mug Club promo code Viking you get
$20 off and send us which countries you
would like to most see in the coming
weeks for cultural appropriation month
hold on I gotta take a nice crowd a ride
stream tweet using the hashtag paper
cigar and you will never know I have how
the band is a rapper if you do it I'm
posting it I will wipe out your
bloodline wow yeah link the link to
extreme right on blaze TV is in the
description but before we do that and
wrap this up here on YouTube it is time
for tonight's
7 + 1 do not forget the whoa it's an
important round especially if you're a
rooftop Korean or German yeah 7 + 1 7 +
1 most often heard excuses when caught
looting Oh
alright these are the 7 plus 1 and these
actually come to us I believe from the
DOJ demo so you know this you know it's
it's tough nuts yeah and if you don't
ask Don Lemon so most often heard
excuses when caught looting yeah 7 + 1
number 7 oh you mean it isn't looting
Tuesday love Ludington also Tuesday
Ludington 7 + 1 most often turn excuses
when caught looting number 6 sorry
officer I can't be tear gassed I have a
doctor's note that seems like you've got
a doctor's note to you don't you know
you don't do the tear yeah I assume that
also means for the projectile in the eye
right yeah no that separate notes I have
myopia please don't put the canister in
my eye
something's what's almost often hurt
excluding number 5 officer that
windshield was like that when I got here
well yeah no I don't think it was number
four excuses for looting Wow
number four reporting my name is Senne
and a half err ones but they closed
early so that's a tough one yeah you
know what it's not without compassion
from my part somebody's got a job you
know I mean Edmunds closes early am I
not going to break the front window yeah
you didn't want that you should have
gotten resistant sorry I work till 5:00
oh whatever
especially when you pull that [ __ ] where
it closes at 9:00 but you close it 55
another no no no no no no no now I
robbed you at home number three seven
plus one most heard excuses when caught
looting look over there officer
churchgoers get him that that's actually
pretty good yeah good yeah get the
churchgoers they say we're gonna come
from the DOJ the Bureau of crime crime
statistics let me see I have three
things here three this is a picture of
Don lemons dick why do we have a fax
machine
Oh weight loss thing what's this video
showing a heavily drunk day yeah that
was Monday well he came around the
corner now I don't know if he knew who
it was
Myers good shot I love how we use that
shield as an egg it's got a camera that
his guys say no no the parish mail and
that camera was black protest just wanna
yeah and they stopped by the way because
this is seen as America's original sin
slavery and right they must have it
everywhere Australia Paris London all
over parently the cops all had a secret
meeting and said listen even if we don't
necessarily have a culture of slavery
with black people we're gonna we're
gonna be brutal right with that if the
pedo sees the people of color yeah it'll
be this will be an international
coalition let's do it ah seven plus one
most often heard excuses when people are
caught looting from the DOJ number two
wait you mean that was you mean that was
your window that seems like you know
item yeah
I can't be keeping track of yeah whose
windows belong do you go there guard the
windshield and make sure it doesn't get
cracked in oh you talking about the
trunk no no you make sure the windshield
doesn't get kicked in
oh I'll kick in his windshield and then
make sure he doesn't get out no no what
where are you going I'll go with you
seven plus one most often heard excuses
when caught looting number one officer I
misunderstood the term fire sale plus
one that is most often heard in most
offices got looting oh I'm sorry I
thought this was America
now that has been this week seven plus
one don't forget it don't forget the
walnut tree that's really just a public
service around here you supposed to be
safe
they're showing the guy who got pushed
by the officer which again we all saw
way out of line way out of line that's
that's ten he's out that ain't old - you
see all the people helping him and
calling for medical assistance that guy
was calling every help but attacking
they've also got protesters attacking
them oh and the medic what's right there
kneeling down right now how badly Don
Lemon doesn't understand oh yeah by the
way you lie in drink happen at the same
time won't tolerate your racist [ __ ] Don
Lemon has trouble he has trouble reading
he's like you know Asperger's yeah and
that he has trouble reading some cues so
you can see when the officer goes like
this right away calls over a medic Don
Lemon has a difficult time reading
communication unless it involves a
yellow bandanna out of the back pocket
which by the way means you pitch and
catch right he picks up those signs
terrible but right away the guy's being
tended to yeah
immediately what is that now that's
important why
yeah one officer out of line and other
officers recognized it right away tried
to step in the guy the guy who pushed
him leaned down to stop and then another
guy pushed him along and started calling
people well cuz they were say I was like
because it was a minute and realized
what he done started leaning down he
said I'll call him I'll take care of ya
because they had protesters right and
break-ins they're people coming right
now I will say maybe even a minority
here cuz I know that that seems
excessive but again those police
officers are clearly moving to clear
away does it change the context when
fire trucks can't get through right yeah
and buildings are being lit on fire does
it change the context when people have
been taking shots at officers does it
change the context when there have been
Molotov cocktails and the police say
move back move back move back
could that have been an example of what
we saw earlier today with a very
peaceful officer saying please don't go
into this perimeter and one guy saying
we don't got a few at nine o'clock
another guy saying y'all can leave or
stay no you can't y'all leave well and
this is this is not happening in a
vacuum either this is after nine nights
of rioting right and killing people and
hurting people and burning stores down
and breaking everything that you can
find in burning cars yeah like this is
not like oh hey this is gonna be another
peaceful night this is this is night
nine four officers living on the edge
every single night instead of one day of
justice we got nine nine crazy night
okay let's go reg let's let me see you
look at their Burt Ward what and look at
his hair I'm jealous
just perfect all the time perfect all
right stop it the officer or at rented
old man that was pushed on by the two
officers that officers have already been
suspended yeah he is in stable condition
okay and it is worth noting that the
curfew was already in place then right
right so you're already violating curfew
so again not not to say that oh that was
fine or whatever but we've been through
months we are salon owners if it's sent
to prison for daring to cut hair right
right right
he's insane enforcement so you have tons
of people violating curfew and I I do
have a clip from auric where a my PD
finally started enforcing the curfew and
rounding you can you put
real quick because let me say I want to
restate my position here a little bit
because I think honestly might have been
unfair and I noticed will be unpopular
because there's a visceral reaction to
seeing a man get hurt because he falls
back and he hits his head in the
concrete
yeah I've shoved you harder than that on
a daily basis when congratulating you
like yeah when you said you were having
I know you're having a baby
whoa good you didn't tell me
congratulations and I fell and hit my
head you're bleeding out and everything
that is not that shove if you watch it
was not the kind riddle you could
deliver that shove to a hundred
different people a hundred different
times and that happens once yeah yeah
now here's the question if an officer is
enforcing a curfew and you were still
there and you were refusing to move and
again there have been acts of violence
beyond comprehension four nights
if you can't shove somebody back what do
you what do you do yeah if you pick him
up in fireman's carry him out yeah yeah
you don't I mean like what do you what
do you do I didn't very spry well I mean
what do you think was gonna happen at a
protest or a riot when he's staying
there when police are moving forward he
is just looking for a place to fall down
as it doesn't justify their behavior at
all right but this guy this guy was
gonna move he was gonna fall over some
way somehow during a protest but an
officer who shoves a man on his chest
not that hard by the way yeah can we can
we show that clip can we see the clip
again of him sure gonna pull it back up
let's pull that back on it I wish that
he had if you had one arm shove him or
did he use both hands I think he uses
both hands does he use both hands well
there's two cops in it which one
actually did the show it makes a
difference if you actually understand
what these people are reacting to like
if you're just show the police officers
doing one thing and you don't have again
nine days before there's now this sort
of stuff that's happening well what do
you come on tonight keep in mind rewind
the tape the curfew and they said well
we're not gonna honor the curfew we you
can leave or you can stay if you're an
officer and you're trying to clear a way
for first responders you're trying to
make sure that's a safe area and you say
this is the curfew it's already been set
it's already been sent out like an Amber
Alert from the governor and then you've
reiterated it peacefully and
respectfully and we've seen people say
no we're not going to honor it
what can you do if not a shove that's my
question
what else would be better and I don't
know so let's see the shove again I know
what does he do he's going he's walking
up to them as they're trying to do it
that's the one that no that's the one
yeah one that's a one-handed shove I'm
sorry that's the one that go back to
that let's play it again that is not an
officer trying to kill somebody
that's an officer who's shoving him off
of the other officer yeah come on and
then right away when he realizes he hit
his head he calls for he calls for a
medic and and by the way this is like on
a morphine drip from CNN do you know
it's not it's it's Dorn laying on the
ground actually dying yeah I want to
show that they are gonna show a guy who
did hit the back of his head and his
bleeding and officers tended to him
immediately and medics were called and
they knelt down even though Don Lemmon
says it didn't happen it was on video
don't believe your lying eyes they're
not gonna show door how do they lie so
blatantly it is I wish that it hadn't
happened but this is my question you
guys can tweet me what do you do if you
are a police officer you are in a city
that has been turned into a war zone we
have over a dozen deaths
we have over 370 officers probably 400
now who violently attacked or seriously
injured you have 25 million dollars in
property damage and Minneapolis alone my
guess is it's probably gonna be in the
billions as well as property it'll never
open back up economic uestion what do
you do we talk about de-escalation well
as far as I'm concerned de-escalation is
governor sends out curfew yeah officer
says please you can stay there but this
is the curfew this is a police line and
then when officers are marching and
there are several instances there where
the officers are not being violent with
them as they continue to move they keep
in there by the way they're not walking
up to shove them it's basically a stiff
on yeah are they supposed to let that
man mingle in through the police line
is it is it terrible that a man had his
head in the concrete am I glad that he's
in stable condition yeah yes is that an
example of a cop who tried to physically
harm somebody or end their life no I
don't think so and I don't know that's a
police officer should be removed from
the force I'm sorry I don't
may not be popular but you have to
answer me what should the cop do in that
instance if not a shove with one arm
what's a lot well yeah the only reason
that any cop is having to make any of
those decisions is there are a bunch of
things that went wrong
upstream from that yeah
right so a bunch of people have made a
bunch of bad decisions he talked about
earlier imagine it's a man of Capistrano
exactly so I'm at yeah imagine if you
are you were talking about this like you
had a sniper rifle you up there and kind
of what is the firefighters you see the
firefighters your child's in a burning
building what happened and then they're
right warmed by protesters who don't
allow the police line through right what
do you do to save the life of your child
number exactly and nobody's wants to get
into that situation nobody's trying to
get there but again you if you've been
put into that situation you have to make
a call and getting your hands dirty
might be the most you know moral thing
to be doing so in this situation did the
cop wake up that morning going oh I'm
gonna find me an old white guy to kill
right right like well you know what also
know what today I really want to mess up
a James Carville look-alike guy who
can't take a step back to steady myself
right and that's it's not his fault he's
just old right but you know what they're
also not showing they're not showing
that video of the Chicago police officer
the female officer trying to be dragged
on the ground into the crowd of people I
didn't see that on CNN to talk about the
violence that is going on right now in
the riots I didn't see that either but
we're gonna play this a hundred times
over and the reporter and then yeah
right like the reporters they got hit in
the chest I'm sorry that that happened
it probably shouldn't have happened but
you didn't die I don't know what what
should have shouldn't have happened this
is my question cuz the first one goes aw
that was too much but I'm saying that I
think I might have been wrong what
should have happened there's a curve
with the old guy I was talking about the
reporter to get it oh yeah yeah no
you're right um with the old guy there's
a curfew and there's a police wall
coming through saying and you can see
them clearly saying go yeah go move and
then a one-armed shove so is it tough to
watch yes should it not have happened
what should have happened to all the
police stop and go ah crap they're
burning down the there's an old guy
where was that was that DC that was in a
in Buffalo they go oh they're burning
down they're burning down the original
wing Hut could you please move could you
please move because I'd like some
blazing sauce what are they supposed to
do yeah and like I said on Thursday said
please stop because it's only going to
result in more deaths in more harm
we were the ones who wanted peace we
were the ones who encouraged you to take
a page from the modern Tea Party to take
a page yes from the armed protesters at
the Michigan State Capitol yep even
though I don't like the optics that
never happened
yeah but if anyone were to take have
that sort of take on this clip on CNN
then CNN probably wouldn't be as
friendly to all of the different
advertisers that they have coming on but
it is much easier for them to get
advertisers if they take on this opinion
for some reason for some reason one is
allowed and one is profitable right and
one is not allowed well I expect to get
flack for what I'm saying here tomorrow
well now I'm just saying does anyone
have an answer what else can a cop do
rubber ball right yeah mace yes I'm
going to move what I mean he seemed like
a very benign push right right just to
get somebody go in the opposite
direction and they were talking and he
the guy wasn't just standing there in
the police walked up to him this guy
approached the police officer coming
right exactly so that clip again he's
not hand comes down here he stops short
so let's see that can we got something
in his hand
what's it think it's like Y alpha let's
see what it is what it is that he has in
his hand let's see the clip that's lit
up it's loaded okay but that's actually
a perfect freeze frame right there yeah
would anyone here ever dream of
approaching a police officer like that
by the way keep in mind see that cop on
the left run that cop on the Left I were
left looking at the screen he's looking
over all the cops are looking over
saying what's going on here because
they've had too many close calls right
would you ever imagine of walking up to
an officer with a mask on like this
right ever with something in your hand
right nowadays there's tasers that are
in phone cases like right get it get
away from my police on nowadays you
don't hand it up don't shoot the hands
were never up that's a big thing with a
parent understand then yeah let me see
the way he walks because that does
matter as well look at his gate yeah do
you see that yeah they push him after he
does this with his hand it's unfortunate
that he didn't hit his head and by the
way play that again play that again and
then if you can pause it when he reaches
his hand out play it again
okay now his hand comes
what oh wow looked like it was hidden
where's the guy you got like pointing
where's the cops gun yeah right
yeah and that helped yeah just getting a
little bit too clear he's not police off
he just puts his hand out to kind of
distance them to get a little distance
no I don't think I wanna get within no
no I'm saying like hey you're getting
too close like this I'm swinging at him
yes he's doing that he's doing that
several times and maybe you say hey your
shoelace is untied and the cops like I'm
not falling for that old trick again
buddy boy yeah the end of it I don't
know but that guy walks up after curfew
police have already asked him to leave
you can clearly see they're saying hey
move move move
they don't shove him even right away
yeah they're in contact there for a
while then when he starts going like
this to the cops utility belt maybe he
was reaching for a shark repellent spray
look reaching reaching hey hey he reacts
right there
and by the way cops are trained for that
cops are trained if someone reaches
toward your back zero-tolerance not
saying that it's the ideal situation
yeah nobody's happy it happened but I
don't know what a police officer can do
other than shove you back and then oh my
gosh he hit his head and get medics to
you right you mean right away
yeah and the only reason that you know
Don Lemon here his reaction would be
justified is if the cops walked away and
went ha ha ha ha right but they get it
all in help right no right and the only
reason we're talking about this is
because they're like see this is just
further evidence of a brutal I bet
you're gonna stay down Trump's tweeting
about this rather than talking about the
rise of Lisa Murkowski reelection
prospects in 2022 looks somewhat better
at this moment than president Trump's do
that guy on the right looks like an
older James O'Keefe if you are hockey
fighter yeah days these criticisms from
isolated criticism from Republican
senators don't mean all that much unless
a few of them get together and decide to
do something about it
Republicans have 53 seats in the Senate
if four Republican senators got together
and said they're going to just mere
debates to stop things the president
upset a lot of people who's doing did
they darkened Don Lemon with more makeup
does he look significantly darker than
it was very very lighter yeah yeah do
you think they're watching this dream
like they did that time with the scene
in fact check and they review our color
let me remove the Aryan Nation yeah like
I think one of them is watching this
right now and like Don lemons looking
pasty oh yeah so the chyron was like
former military leaders criticized
president Trump's response to the
protest response but again you play a
clip of two people and that's supposed
to be representative of the military's
response to this now the military is
sort of going yes sir and going and
doing their job yeah as you're finding
this because those people are anomalies
because the military members of the
military overwhelmingly vote Republican
and then overwhelmingly support Donald
element and there's no one can even
argue that right they did the exact same
thing with churches right so they bring
on two ministers who are criticizing
Trump what but that doesn't mean it's
representative discuss the current
situation in relation to the American
congregations and Kovac is Unitarian
lead pastor make [ __ ] bucker
congregation of three right yeah so this
is the representative the Christian
community after Bill Ayers what are your
thoughts let's go to Don not dem limit
let's go to reg the Bandit reg you must
called you said you had a clip I'm very
tired with the hockey fighting James
O'Keefe you said you had a clip for us
and then we are gonna go to to blaze
exclusive former club members reg unmute
your mic what do you have for a sir
oh I just have a final clip of people
sort of just rounding up the protest in
New York and the NYPD is just like knows
it meant to leave encouraging them to
leave that looks like a stampede and the
elephant boneyard and landing in the
Lion King
[Music]
see they're doing this right now people
who are refusing to get in line resting
they just grabbed them yeah and I
believe this is like I think it's at
least an hour after the curfew is
supposed to be in effect so they gave
them plenty of time to comply right well
don't you love they're like this curfew
is ridiculous it's trying to silence
protest as opposed to barbers who were
protesting in the middle of day yeah
right and they go well why is it cuz
their wife you're letting get arrested
no again the through line here is crime
they were not committing crimes you are
committing a there have been so many
crimes committed that a curfew was
appropriate to protect the rights of
citizens who are not committing crimes
why is this hard when you commit crimes
that infringe on the rights of non crime
committing citizens there's a good
chance you might get your ass beat well
the people getting their hair cut in
Michigan did get fined by the way a
thousand dollar one hell of a flat-top
if they weren't burning the city's down
they probably would have not put in
curfews they probably would be still out
there able to protest and able to
peacefully march if they wanted to but
that's not what I think you're saying
it's a racial thing alright we are going
to wrap and by the way you can see I am
uh if you think I should kneel or not
let me know tweet me your leave it up to
the Bobby blaze livestream I think I
might I think because some people are
saying well you know what if you kneel
you remove that car that they have to
play against you I think you I don't
Broadway old I do think that there may
be a reason to kneel just so that I can
get it over with and be considered an
ally thank you so much for everyone
who's been watching the hashtag is
Crowder riot stream the promo code is
Viking through the end of the night you
get $20 off if you want us to continue
doing the job that journalists won't do
right now we are going to go exclusively
to mug club at legal a description so
the link is in the description youtube
you can go piss up a kite